all right and we are both live power
induced welcome to the last word episode
number 51 and it's another glory it's
Friday night I'm gonna factor in front
of a campfire for some great ludus unit
discussion I'm extremely excited about a
special guests so we go get right into
it I want to introduce the Lord who's
been one of the most consistent and
passionate content creators within our
entire destiny community whether it be
is detail game guides weapon DPS testing
and the owner of the most expressive
reactions you ever witness or livestream
introducing the host of the skerin on
youtube channel a member of the legion
of zerg destiny clan the recently minted
women's bane and the lord of all mother
chickens everywhere god enough to make
his debut within the realm of tlw mommy
lord skerin i mean how you doing sir
dude that was beautiful thank you so
much very well smile on your face right
yeah no for sure like I don't have a
face cam right now but I'm pretty much
right about those reactions pleasure to
have you babe we would talk to you for a
while and um it's good to have you but
how you going man man I'm doing really
well and it's great to be here for sure
how are you guys doing doing well now
Baltasar worried about it but how's he
doing Gatsby here oh man
so let's see head to orchestrate a day
Internet dies on me so that switch
things around not known if it's ever
gonna come back literally get home from
dinner I get the call like from internet
provider saying hey should be back up
get home my rat like my modem showing
green my router looks like you got shot
cuz it's just like two red lights and
nothing else so then I go literally
25-foot like direct cord from the modem
to my computer and it's working so crazy
day but we are here now so thank you all
for showing up tonight and thank you
scare Oh for jumping in anything I can
do man
I was like well short notice to reach
that like the schedule switched and I
knew I wanted to try and get you in here
and yeah short notice
kognito likes to have some time for
intros but I didn't give him enough can
you still crushes it as always he did
not me no time I was on ILP and I was
just like dude I can't I can't talk now
cuz I can't follow that the community
man we got a response Megaman this guy's
been doing for a while and I mean
obviously you know brief history lesson
you know he was kind enough to let us
utilize the name as well and um
definitely want to shout him out for
that cuz that's huge respect I'm saying
it on this guy's been killing it you
know what the guides and everything he's
doing and I caught actually is one of
his latest response reaction videos to
The Drifter I was like oh he's hi easy
to save space I'll bet that's good yeah
absolutely and know what no problem
about the the name we did it for a long
time but you know it came time to pass
it on to new people and you guys are
doing it justice and heck yeah good
stuff gets so much appreciation thank
you very much yeah we were digging deep
and they were trying to figure out the
like the title and everything I about
had kognito wring my neck over it and
stuff like that and then literally the
first thing and I know you and I both
know pyro scare oh yeah we literally
went out and I finally like went live
with the name and he tweeted me was like
dude it was we just hadn't gone back as
far as those literally average that to
you as soon as I could it's like hey and
you couldn't have been nicer man so I
was like I wanted to get you on here you
sounded like you definitely wanted to
get a little podcast and when you can so
we're really excited to have you and I'm
glad we could make it work for sure for
sure our jr. says he thinks no time to
explain would have been late that's
actually what we are the demo for the
last word was called no time to explain
and I thought that was too hard to
design a logo for so I went to the last
sword though there you go
we went through a lot of that stuff -
actually we were flashpoint which works
pretty well for destiny a short and
sweet and then all of a sudden we were
like what would you find a clan or
something with that name
yeah actually there was a eSports league
and we like okay yes we I had no idea it
was brought to my attention and I'm just
like yeah we gonna have to change that
then we thought I did a research to be
like oh you know they thankfully man you
were so cool he bonds has reached out to
you you guys talked and you know cuz I
was really banking on this Wells like
all of it I really like this I already
had all the decals design you like so
cool you just it's cool and to give us
the man to and let us use the legacy you
know it's really really appreciative man
thank you so much now first year first
year thanks for carrying it on like I
said that's that you know you guys are
doing to justice and just keep it going
keep it going past so in case you guys
have been living under a rock or just
felt like not you know paying attention
of the world to destiny Ceaser drifter
has exploded with the Vidak the articles
there's so much stuff coming we've got a
ton of stuff to talk about including
shoutouts a whole lot in your chat right
now in ILP he had a great virtually
legality today so you guys haven't
checked him out it's h OE g law kognito
turned me on to him and it was a great
listen today talking about the basically
the Bungie Activision stuff a little
more detail today so we'll get into that
even later if we even have time I have
no idea how long this thing is gonna be
we used to call this flashpoint this one
is definitely gonna be hashtag one point
but season The Drifter of the Vidocq
dropped we know about the different
pieces of it so without too much further
ado we're gonna jump into it hey let's
do it man so Season Of The Drifter is a
thing so March 5th it starts we all know
that and every player season that effort
will begin you've got different stuff
for all the people without the end
you'll pass and then even more for
people with the annual pass the annual
passes the big stuff so we are gonna
start there now we're not going to go
through the full viaduct we've got a lot
of pieces to talk about which we've been
covering the main bullet points on it
but playing a video you guys can watch
that on your own but we're gonna start
and kind of go through this with the
calendar first and
as we hit a high point we're gonna kind
of break down our discussions on it so
Calandra be on screen for a little bit
for the season of The Drifter and then
we'll kind of hit each piece as we go
first thing
gambits Prime I just want to get you
guys initial impressions on this whole
new mode mmm that's not what's going on
because he had the great reaction so I
want to hear so I was in a really weird
place for this DLC because when I was
grinding for dredgen I did it before the
triple infamy and all that I was sick of
it and so I was I was going into this
DLC thinking like I'm not gonna like
this at all and as soon as I saw those
glowing armor sets I was like oh Bungie
has brought the bacon like I knew they
were confident they were knew like they
knew exactly what they wanted to do and
then as they started talking about the
roles and just everything man it's gonna
breathe so much life into gambit and in
the entire kind of community around it
and the fact that it's like a fast-paced
one round type of game mode it's
competitive I'm just so excited it looks
rewarding it looks like a lot of fun and
to pull a player like me who was kind of
sick of gambit like I said I never
wanted to touch it again into someone
who's foaming at the mouth for it
Bungie has done a fantastic job I'm
really excited yeah man I mean I
couldn't say they're better than this
guy so from me shout out to the dude in
the chat and I'll pee chat you know he
actually made a good point I listened to
those guys over there tower talk and um
it almost felt like you know the
evolution of like how trials was to
stand it crucible it's kind of that
evolution for for gambit and I'm just
loving you know the specified roles and
it was definitely surprised you know I
came in you know very low expectation
coming in with the drifter and I know
we're gonna get deeper we're gonna dive
deep into all the different things that
are you know consist of this content but
man like this was not what I expected
and um we're gonna get into the 9 I
wanna talk about that I got a lot that
surprised me but um yeah man like just
on the the mold itself and the specified
roles really change gambit and I and one
last thing I'll say is that the the
urgency of the
one round that definitely is gonna turn
it up a notch so yeah I'm height man I
am hi this is definitely a pleasant
surprise so let's get it what you think
II yeah I mean I'm kind of like the way
both you guys were especially you scare
oh well you played a lot recently I
played some towards the beginning and I
think a lot of us had had our fill of
gambit we gotten used to it I think all
of us had been hidden by Queen breaker
enough after craft I mean you know it's
true I mean it's one of the things
they're hitting in the sandbox but it
was just that feeling of and they I
think I mean I've missed 5000 or any of
those people who like and true Vanguard
when they go play in a vacuum with a set
of weapons and it's not all the crazy
stuff that can sometimes break the game
gambit actually looks really fun to
trade back and forth the invasions on
all that stuff actually seems like kind
of a fair balance and then you have
stuff where people now they've played
enough they know the invasion spawns and
things gambit was getting to a point
where especially if you go solo it was
brutal no I'm not saying this is gonna
be any better solo but it was the idea
of there's so much orchestration to
where like the boss melting in three
seconds was just out fun so the
mechanics coming in sound amazing armor
sets I cannot tell you how many times I
literally said those two words I thought
oh my I could only see your face when
they vented or beset with specific hurts
heaven right that I'm like I've been
waiting for so absolutely sorry co-heads
girl yeah sorry so just with the armor
sets one thing that I was talking about
yesterday is in addition to bringing
that in I think it's a really great way
to introduce more parody into it because
it the way it seems and I might be wrong
here but each armor set seems to only
have one perk that activates whenever
you are wearing the entire set so that
means if that's true that's that's a lot
of speculation based on the fact that we
got the perks that they all they you
know they provide those buffs and
there's only one of them so if that's
true that means that you're gonna have
to either pick in exotic or to get that
bonus perk as well but we were like one
or the other right and I think that'll
introduce a lot more even playing field
making it a lot less focused on these
kind of broken exotics like shards of
the gallon or and celestial Nighthawk
and things like that and I think that'll
be really good for the mode and
terms of competitiveness as well mm-hmm
absolutely absolutely there's so much to
and what I like about it what they've
done with this is that they've they've
truly analyzed how gambits has been
played right and you can tell with how
these roles are constructed that they
really look at okay there are guys that
come in and all they want to do is
invade or there's guys that want to sit
there and all they want to do is just
rush to the most as soon as you're gonna
say the match starts and stuff like that
and guys they want to defend it just so
I love the analyzation of the mode and
and truly given these roles and and
benefitting people who want to do those
roles and we'll get into the reckoning
and all that stuff as well - but did
it's really good on munchies part I
gotta give credit when credit is due
like I did not expect this deep dive but
to be honest I thought it would be
something simplistic I didn't think you
know seasoned adrift there will be some
form of change in gambit but not to this
level so kudos to them yeah it is
definitely pleasant surprise absolutely
I mean me the other piece for me has
been the fact that you've got just a
little stuff about the colors if you're
playing with people on your team and
there weren't a full light or a full
what is the invader set the full red you
know like you know what go ahead if you
want to be the invader but like that
like non communication communication
like where you you know not voice chat
or say anything you just look at that
person be like hey they're gonna invade
they've spend the time they got the full
set let's see how they do
like I mean and let him go if somebody's
got the full collector I might pull a
little farther back and actually give
them that role so it's those little
subtle hints - randoms that I think
actually could help even randoms to be
more successful if they actually pay
attention to it but if somebody's
wearing full white and they're the
collector I'm gonna back off and let you
kind of get in the mix a little more and
lay your role and that's actually really
really cool real quick right now what
you guys lead into what would you put
each of you personally like wet scout
what are you leaving - okay look I I'm
I'm the the
resident dick of my team I write to
Queen breakers up you know all right so
the inside joke called the fire shout to
fights you chat he had a great stream
with a legion Lars and a Bungie dead
I've got her name and she called of like
the red they call him invader pants and
I almost passed how did you catch it
because they were asking if you can mix
and match and he was like well you can
have your red invader pants and they
just wouldn't let the invader pants
thing go Rose got his invader paints yes
no what about you cog Mina oh you know
what's funny
I mean shout the whole Glo he's like
right now is there a killer role like a
yeah there I mean yes and I believe is
that the century I believe no the
century is the one at the bank centuries
the one at the bank and then there's one
that kind of is a second it's kind of a
stool rolled on yeah they're layer the
Reaper the Reapers which are looking for
clears wave slay large enemies that's
for you yeah like I'm the guy that when
I'm maintaining that area emotional
muscle to take care of everyone else is
you know blockers that they they put up
so when the block has come wait are you
are clearing enemies I'm clearing
enemies more so okay so there's two
different ones they look the Reaper
clear way of slay larger enemies
centuries under invaders and protect
your bank I do a little century action
but I think I'm more of a Reaper I think
I yeah because you know that and I like
to hoard the heavy so da Reapers me they
get mad at because I'm next to the power
brick as soon as it's ready to spoil me
to the Lord I'm gonna go put some work
in on the other side yes so you are
actually one who could potentially go
half green half yellow and this was
gonna actually clarify for us Cairo
since they're there yeah yeah it's like
absolutely and they dug deep on fire
team chat so it was nice they said you
can't go split now the full complete
color-glo crazy that's if you go full
set and there's a pinnacle perk that you
can gosh yeah so there's a pinnacle
blurk that you get by wearing them all
but
you go half century half Reaper you
might be kind of a mix or like a hybrid
and it's still possible you just may not
Clovis much but the color will be there
but just like the chroma glow from d1
won't be quite as vibrant okay and you
don't get the major perk for that yeah I
don't know I know for example one of the
really high cool perks like the
collector
there's the collector I don't know if
it's a pinnacle or not but you can hold
20 motes and you can basically summon a
I joked on Twitter it was like big booty
big booty blocker but it was but it was
like a giant blocker and she said jumbo
blocker been there laying its giant
blocker and she's like either way like
the extra one that nobody else gets to
so I don't know if that would be
pinnacle but it sounds like it would be
I think they would be that does sound
like a definitely good one I think I
tweeted all four of him earlier today
I'm trying to find it
yeah they just sound crazy for sure and
then that that's so exciting and think
if we get like stuff like this for raids
and the future in one not like oh now
we're glad that's the evolution that's
what we wanted that's what we thought we
were gonna get when uh we know when
destiny to launch and we thought we're
gonna get more evolution specific roles
that help with specific mode just want
to answer a quick question that Laura
had about colorblind modes and yes they
are being addressed um within this we're
gonna get into that when we get to the
twelve but uh yeah they definitely
thought about that as far as color blind
accessibility absolutely did and shout
out to Bungie again hitting stuff like
that that I don't even think of so
writable that's yeah oh it's very good
accessibility in their games anyways
back to we'll get back to this page
don't worry is who wants to break it
down scare over kognito when you guys
want to break down the actual mode I
know we've been like ranting and raving
about our excitement about it alright so
gambit prime is like if you took trials
the sweatiness of trials and the
sweatiness of gambit and you made them
have a baby and you just took the most
concentrated one around form of gambit
where it's just 4v4 with specific roles
you know everyone can pick these armor
sets that you get through the reckoning
which will probably go over here in a
second and they give you these extra
perks and they'll help you fit into your
role a little
more but there's some changes based off
of the general gameplay of regular
gambit so for instance the invader can
now steal modes from the other side like
I mentioned there's only one round and
that plays a big role into it as well
and then the boss has rave like
mechanics where you have to work with
your team to really take that down that
boss as quickly as possible so it's not
just like who has three storm power
warlocks no it's it's gonna be more like
hey we need to wet which mechanic did we
get this time assuming there's different
mechanics for the two day four Maps
maybe not and how do we conquer this to
really get the edge on the other team
and it essentially the way I'm looking
at it it's gambit but instead of more
it's a little bit more PvE focused than
the regular gambit I I would I kind of
am weaning towards that might not be
true in the final build we'll have to
see but it definitely seems like they're
leaning more towards the hardcore PvE on
this one with a very important PvP
aspect as well that's going to be more
reliant on a single person or maybe two
people if you build your team like that
yeah it's really exciting I love the
aspect of me the mechanics of a boss
like you said like you know something
where it just doesn't come down to okay
you know melt fast strategies you know
yeah and you're gonna have to work
together you know again everyone's got
specific roles and then the cool thing
is you have the options that you know
they showed it on streem like there's
gonna be some team that is gonna be like
all invaders yeah that's terrifying by
the way just you know like you say one
of the cool things again but you know
just before the match start you see the
other team get to face almost like a
fighters faceoff so you're gonna get to
end okay wow they got you know two
centuries they got a Reaper they got you
know and it's just gonna have this whole
little meta within the game you know and
it is just really really cool and and
again I just want emphasizing again that
one round right one round yeah round
because one of the biggest complaints
you know about gambit as much as we
loved it and I got a chance to debut the
the role at e3 or last year shall to uh
Sean Finegan salute
my supposed to keep a shower he's uh
he's moved on from my fire team chat
great guy I got that was who I actually
got a chance to play gambit with for the
first time you know when they revealed
it early and we were like this is great
the only negative was just that the
matches tend to go long right it's a
three match and now we know they've made
changes I believe last um the last where
we did last all week uh he that they
talked about standard gambit now third
round will be boom you know just the
primary was born and you just go right
sudden-death basically right but still
in general the mo tends to take long
when I'm doing my miles total for the
week I'm like Manny's game it matches
three okay take a lot and that shouldn't
take like 20 minutes I mean that's a
long time for anything especially if you
lose if you're going for especially if
you're going for infamy you spend like
20 minutes and I met like a two-round go
for three maybe some one of them's long
and you lose your look yeah yeah it's
kind of defeating now the real question
is is there going to be a meatball 2.0
for gambit probably not I honestly think
there's gonna be a few of those on on
the stream they mentioned that all
goodness gracious thing I should tell
you and you're gonna just be up all
night long we're just gonna keep feeling
you're so exciting you and those guys
they asked specifically you know because
of the fact that you know meatball was
kind of specific to gambit you know they
said actually as a result of gambit
crime there will be more of a chance for
it to spawn there for people who have
missed it and then oh but just the
regular meatball though um that they
didn't get specific today did they say
okay so big they clarified the ascender
primeval meatball is going to be an even
spawn for regular gambit like literally
just in there along with anything else
so you'll see a lot which will be good
gambit Prime and the bosses are gonna be
all of them are gonna have more
mechanics to them they stayed I don't
know if they're different bosses if the
meatball is one of them but they all
said there's more mechanics and they
didn't say raid like kind of stuff but
it's there's definitely more mechanics
to them I forget the actual terminology
but they definitely mentioned more
mechanics a little bit of a puzzle
figuring out trying to take these guys
down it's just not melting it which
sounds exact
like what they needed to do yeah
absolutely man it's just so cool I
cannot wait oh so much to talk about
then we recommend we got stuff to talk
about but I was like hey I warned
everybody up front maybe a minute yeah
so yeah gambits Prime one around one
boss now this one is a hundred motes so
it's not seventy-five so it's definitely
more now the other thing that they
talked about in this one is you can lose
motes yes your bank can actually start
lowering and in the podcast that
clarifies if you have more than I think
it's if you have two blockers up you can
start losing yes losing motes out of
your bank so if more than one is up you
can definitely be in trouble so that's
where having that collector dropped that
jumbo and then if you throw like a
couple goblins in there and they got
that shield thing going on yeah it's
gonna be trouble so and then on top of
the collector being I don't know if the
collector or invader maybe being a being
able to also sound like they could help
like steal motes from the bank later can
steal I so I think his his super or his
super perk or whatever actually allows
him to count as a blocker and so when
you're in there you can if there's
another blocker you're helping speed up
the rate that they're stealing the most
this cool part about this is that as an
invader you can have a dual strategy
there's no more just I'm gonna go kill
guardians right right now you can just
hang out your evil but that's all I was
I was like all I'm scared of is like
these Titan bubbles in full force like
I'm worried about the fun policeman and
now teams can't hide in the back of the
mat because if they do on the bank
because that was my strategy smelled
like I would I'm like waiting their
streak hot we pull out you know idiot
you know kind of dig and then kind of
hang out I can no longer do that because
for my understanding right correct me if
I'm wrong just their mere presence with
that perk as a blocker
he's morale draining moats yep I think
so now if there would be two oh one more
there why
there's one more blocker on the field
yeah yeah so if they had one more block
and and that strategy that destroys my
whole gameplay loop I have to come out
of hiding I have to go get you it ain't
for the invader to not keep running into
spawn camping you're honestly more
incentivized to actually sit on the bank
and hold that thing down so there's a
lot of different play you could just
honestly if you're a good sniper and
people are like worried about hiding and
there's a couple you know blocker
sitting on there you just being in there
for 30 seconds is now pulling back like
those modes which is all you just your
presence alone can do stuff tipping I'm
worried eyes and some warlock strategies
against you II have already already got
got some mental warfare gold I think
what I'm gonna have to do with you
Titans are we're gonna need a well
radiance on the left side and the right
side we're gonna need our own Titan
bubble like right in the middle so we
can't answer it I am izanagi's Burton
and still shoot your head off caddy
quits go bro I gotta stop you guys from
Kate from hey get out I was like and I'm
hoping that this will bring gambit back
all of the excitement the were all
talking about right now is the exact
opposite of how I felt lately I'm like I
haven't look at my game but three
matches for the week I'm like I was like
and now I'm like this could be fun and
I'm just hoping they have and I'm on my
two things one I hope they if it is if
people find stuff that is broken they're
fast enough to change it not the usual
three-month cadence or whatever it is
and two I just hope it lives halfway up
the vibe of this and then I'm gonna be
fine yeah absolutely
this is oh good stuff man let's get
let's get into this stuff it's good it's
an arrest ah
so what happens when you finish a gambit
prime match so while you're going
through gambit you're gonna be picking
up doing different things whether you
finish the matches of victory or they
said there's other things that might do
it as well you get something called
since and those are gonna allow you to
go into the reckoning
so the reckoning is Cognito Esguerra
I'm gonna pass
after one of you guys yeah like this is
cool man first off you know
let me give us cows um full disclosure
oh I'm a big Osiris family right
so when trials of the nine was
introduced you know I mean I wasn't the
biggest fan from a law wise because I
felt he should have been Osiris is of it
but um to see them utilize you see the
Lord utilized in this fashion and this
reckoning but you kind of go within the
drifter ship I believe now they still
have to explain the connection on how it
almost looks like the trials map they
have to explain that I don't understand
we're in the ship but we're in you know
kind of the nines area but whatever and
um it's like this insane it almost feels
like horde mode meets escalation
protocol with just mad yeah and a little
bit of crota trade right with just pure
waves and and McCann and then on top of
that they throw on a timer mechanic
right so attention the difficulty
they're gonna tear this thing out along
a couple of weeks and from my
understanding the way the game game
played loop works is that as you
complete that that's what gets you that
gear to then go back into gambit to be
able to utilize those roles and stuff so
it's like you know playing gamma prime
going into the reckoning you know going
back and forth and there's this gameplay
loop of that so this is very interesting
I wanted to know sky like was your
feeling when you saw this whole
reckoning deal so I just want to start
off by saying like you must be excited
for this because the first thing I think
that you mentioned last week in your
show was that you were dying to find out
what was inside the drifter ship and
there was like the first thing they
showed us that's it that's pretty funny
but I I would look when they showed the
drifter talking to the nine I was just
white you can't do that like that's how
this works
yes I was realizing I guess they pulled
some curveballs on us I don't know how
that because I was I was all dead set
like oh the drifter is a bad guy you
know what well you know what to be
honest team initially but we're gonna
get them or whatever yeah and then
they've thrown the 9 inch like oh man we
can't really screw with him but
in terms of like the reckoning as a
game-mode I'm excited I I've got a lot
of really high hopes for this and
especially with the three different
tiers and I'm hoping that there's some
rewards they haven't showed us yet so we
know that there's obviously these
armored sets that come from reckoning
all the gambit prime armor sets but I'm
hoping that there's some kind of like
top tier endgame ish ones like like
cosmetics like a like a ghost or sparrow
or something that maybe that would
traditionally be associated with like a
title or something maybe there's going
to be a quote-unquote Petrus run version
of reckoning tier three or something I
think that would be really cool the the
one thing that's really gonna make or
break reckoning for me is how do they
really differentiate it from the Haunted
Forest and festival the loss they seem
to have very very similar kind of ideas
behind them the difference is being the
reckoning looks a lot more fast-paced
that could just be a little bit of kind
of marketing magic or something yeah but
it just you know if I I'm excited for it
looks fast-paced they did exactly
compared to the the lanterns part of
Curtiss raid kurtas n excuse me and so I
mean that makes me really excited I'm
just I have to wait I I we haven't seen
as much about this so I don't know
exactly how to feel about it just yet I
guess so
where you at with this whole thing with
the reckoning um well for one this is
one of those things when bungees like
hey because we were talking even the
last week I'm like or is there
information I know it's gonna be close
to we're gonna get information later
it's probably just gonna be some gambit
stuff and then BAM completely do PvE or
and what I was like and once again give
me something to think about
so that alone at least was a nice step
because nobody hadn't clue this thing
was coming not gambit related completely
separate nice little loop to tie in its
match made all three tiers are which is
good mmm-hmm I like the idea of the when
they hit the crotas raid horde mode
abyss section that was one thing that
has me happy because that the feeling of
that mode is exactly how a
I've read should have felt like yeah
that's the way that started and I was
like that's exactly how that would go
you invade a hive base guess what 6000
throw I'll come at you good luck lady
how that would go and this looks like
stuff spun out on the walls constantly
flying at you bigger stuff behind and if
it's just like a mad rush and that's
like kind of when you talked about
haunted forest it was kind of a worry as
well but from what I'm seeing it I'm
hoping it's not the sections and the
demons that you have to knock out that
it's just this either constant wave or a
stream and you're trying to get to the
bosses where it's a more continuous
thing not these like chunks
bigger Longer thing so right I don't
know how how long do you guys think a
reckoning round would be I'm trying to
figure out how long this thing actually
would be oh man
it's I mean if it's that fast-paced you
got to imagine around can't go for more
than 10 minutes right like there comes a
point where there's gonna be like the
return on action to fun is very awesome
total like it'll it'll level off
eventually
um man I don't know that's an excellent
question actually how long with lanterns
would you say probably a five to seven
minute encounter without cheese's
probably yeah somewhere around there I
think that's a pretty safe bet maybe you
know Tier three might be a little bit
more crazy than that it depends if they
had like checkpoints and stuff it seems
like it's it's a you know Tier one
you're supposed to do in one sitting so
yeah five to seven minutes maybe a
little bit longer in higher tiers
possible yeah because they're being it
like you said there's that there's that
point there's that sweet spot that they
have to hit and um yeah man I mean it is
so interesting to me to see how that
part is handled you know they're
definitely linked in these modes they
want that gameplay loop to be you go
into the wreck and you come back - um -
gamete prime so yeah I would say like
that yeah five or seven minute mark
should be kind of the sweet spot and you
know because anything too long then it
becomes you know we're getting into like
okay as we we're gonna be doing like a
strikers look like that like we turned
it into a mini raid be like is this like
chatot grown now protect me I gotta wipe
the sweat off my hands real quick I
can't
I cannot do this one last thing is you
know again back to the law for me
personally like this is my Hopi is I'm
the biggest Osiris fanboy my hope is
even though Osiris they made this
statement and he said trials is not
coming back with any type of near future
which saddened me I went on a crazy rant
scanner like you don't even know about
the rain I don't think my feelings that
we call the last word but oh you know
what gives me hope is that he could come
back you know whether it be d3 or
whatever because they are clearly
associated her the chick with the one
sock that I will not name I was actually
looking at the picture trying to figure
out I was like I saw him like what this
whole one sock thing because you weren't
wrong he was trying to figure out but
knows like here's the picture of God it
actually doesn't look like a socket
looks like her foot had like frostbite
like pose down here so I like I don't
understand I'm like where is Osiris I
don't want to talk to you oh wait don't
get me started going on I can't believe
I've never done that much attention
because I only did trials like beautiful
but anyway stories jokes aside like I
loved it they're timeless to him like
Smurfs Caro said you know maybe if this
evil you know like this this master play
going on and then we've also seen her
during um what's a cursed week right she
was within a new dealer on Mars right so
it's a lot going on with this and I just
like her over this they did gambit I
loved it and now we get more stuff
hashtag my trials on my head by
we get her again invitations overnight
yes separate away you know say so give
my man a chance to get his Redemption
his glorious DLC the way it was supposed
to be I'm getting height for that aspect
to BES it is this is ringing personal
narrative bells for me yeah so basically
on March 5th when all this stuff goes
down we're gonna get Gambhir Prime and
reckoning tier 1 and we're gonna get
gambit Prime map new Arcadia so we've
got the map which I believe new Arcadia
is the Mars one is that right good core
yeah yeah because the Titan was 12 I
remember that one name yeah yeah so did
it is Mars yeah okay so those two come
first and tier one they said is gonna be
I guess like maybe I don't know if
that's gonna be like your class item in
your boots but they said you're not
gonna be able to get the full set of
gambit prime armor until tier 3 comes
out so I don't know if you get some
pieces as you go if you're kind of
building up to get to tier 3 I'm not
sure how the like level you know the
slow release of this is actually gonna
come out because we've got March 5th
here one March 8th this tier 2 a couple
other things we'll talking about in a
second and then March 15th this tier 3
so even a week later so it's that
following Friday for tier 3 so I don't
actually know what the distinction
between those are gonna be how the armor
pieces are gonna come back like it
sounds like on reckoning tier 1 like
during this first couple of days you're
not gonna be able to get a full set of
armor unless I'm crazy that sound right
yeah I mean it makes sense as well if
they followed the same type of thing
that they were doing with black armory
which which I'm totally for by the way
kind of leading us along like that it
would be a good way to keep us doing
that and you know it's a kind of adds
the replayability make it so we kind of
have to farm for these because they seem
like they're gonna be pretty static
rolls this is something you guys can
clarify for me do you get one piece of
armor that you can apply any of the four
roles to like though game barrels do oh
good you take it because I gotta tell
you what I remember afterwards so
basically what they said is you're gonna
get sense of a specific type
so you're gonna get like a sentry synth
and then you take it into the reckoning
you try and make it all the way all the
way to the end and you like put it in
this little like portable Bank they said
and then if you finished that reckoning
I don't know which tier is gonna get you
the armor but if you like run in with
the Reaper very percent then you if you
finish it then you have a chance to get
that Reaper armor so you actually pick
which one you want to try for when you
go for your reckoning run but they
aren't or individual armor sets there's
four sets correct yeah so yeah so
literally that's 12 sets with three
characters nothing yeah and so at that
first week they only give us let's say
they follow this traditional order that
they set up for us an escalation where
it goes class item boots arms chest and
then helmet every week you know that
like you said that's six pieces of armor
to farm for every week until the third
one and no oh my gosh it's even more
that it's 12 per per week oh my goodness
yeah so yeah you know we gotta clarify
something on perks I got a question for
you guys
um what the waiting made it seemed again
correct me if I'm wrong was that the
perk set they almost like you can pick a
path as far as for the access certain
game at armors on on certain perks is
that confirmed
or is that true so basically the way
they stated is because you'll have
you'll want to wear an exotic somewhere
in there everybody's going to wear one
and they said there's a way to either I
don't know if it's put a synth into
something or like buff something up a
little bit more it sounded like you
could still have your full pinnacle perk
and yes we're an exotic with some
comradeship these elements or since or
something right because my understanding
is that because they say like you said
like there's gonna be people who like
hey I want to wear an exotic if I break
up the set so to speak does that do I
lose you know the perk functionality and
the vibe I got was that the perks
operate outside let's just say for
example I don't know I'm just making up
theoretically like it was in the
consumers pool section or some separate
section that once you acquire the gear
and you pick the perks it's in this
section as opposed to on the gear that
if you take off
the chess piece or whatever that you
lose a perk that that was the way I
understood it but is that how you got it
like how did you guys get it uh so I
think I think you would have to equip
them to actually get like the benefits
you know and it sounds like if you did
split too much like you know if you want
half Reaper half century you couldn't
get the pinnacle perk but it sounded
like you had four you still could get
the pinnacle and maybe use one exact so
it's gonna take a pretty decent set but
my guess would be you're probably gonna
have to equip them God everybody's
wearing them I don't think you're gonna
have like this you know synth stat or
something like that now there may be a
some or maybe they change the UI or
something like that you'll actually be
able to see like unlocking perk trees or
something like that I don't know for
like gibbet but I do think you're gonna
probably have to have to have them equip
to even have a chance to do that I'm
just not sure how the the extra benefit
from something works with an exotic yeah
absolutely we gotta get clarity on now
yeah man this is this is exciting is
this is really cool stuff man I'm I'm
loving them finally tackling armor with
the same level of detail and intensity
that they're so good at with weapons
right and weapon person we've always
fought me ebon toises about the ban is
on island man he's been championing this
thing for so obvious it's obvious its
arm assess man now if we can just get
our exotic armor catalysts oh my god
speed preaching to the choir here trust
me we definitely are in the same boat
it's cool again pleasant surprise
didn't think didn't expect much from
this and this this is really cool
direction okay
so gambit prime map to deep-six that
one's gonna be on Titan and nothing
looked like it had conveyor belts on it
do you guys see that in the video yes it
was kind of like the old-school Mario
Kart imagine one side would be going
backwards and one side would be going
forwards except this was a left and
right and I feel like that's that's
gonna be a mainly a problem if you're
strafing away from the bank to get away
from an invader or something it's really
gonna throw off your aim
I think that's gonna be a very
interesting dynamic and another thing is
how does that interact with stuff in the
map like if
traditionally things like ammo blocks
and stuff they kind of like sit above
those sort of moving environments but if
they made motes on those conveyor belts
go around I think that would be a really
kind of cool little extra detail that
could be really cool as well yeah but
none of them enemies would move with the
conveyor belt as well yeah just have
maybe if if you were worried about
invaders you could straight up have a
strategy where you kind of use grenades
solar grenades to push like an ogre on
the outside conveyor belt and just have
them like rotate around the center here
you're the visual Lord that is hilarious
some pro stress I'm gonna instead of
first right here right here I called it
a p.m. March 1st all yours so yeah we've
got a new map then which seems
apparently by our thoughts of just the
moving conveyor belt should be
interesting and then we've got the
reckoning tier 3 on March 15th I'm
skipping one thing you guys know why
because it's a pretty big difference
March 19th we've got legions folly that
one looks like it's all over where would
that one be so I guess two new maps are
gonna be new Arcadian than deep six
yeah and it's calling emerald coast look
like the two old maps yeah yeah they are
okay yeah yeah so you got the one on
Nessus and little one obviously on etz
so or have for gambit prime Maps but to
our brand new of course so that's cool
and then all maps available on the April
second private matches will be available
for gambit prime as well a private match
for game at prime I mean when you're in
a bit either one like do you find any
incentive in that would you even just go
around in there like solo one by
yourself just to see how it goes low
wish 15 Wallace gambit print the way he
broke it down was they actually said
that the you know I said you can
actually do it solo they said I don't
know how invading would feel because if
you don't
lissa gambits a funnel at the end of the
day you know if you want to get cups
tree breeze together and you know do
that stuff with just a bunch of butts
listen the option is there as far as
prime the way they explained it on
streams kara was kind of like they want
to keep some newness to Prime's so
they're not gonna have it the private
match of functionality available
initially because I wanted to feel new
they want to feel special she does uh
those new maps so all it will eventually
you know get into there that's funny I'm
not the biggest private match guy even
though I respect the feature under not
that I don't want it there so as
probably at something I'm realizing but
again fun if couple streamers want to
get together and say hey man you know ah
squad the cool thing they didn't mention
though is um you the stuff that you had
issue with which they talked about was
um tweeting oh okay I sell really a bug
we want to save that's how we do so it's
like you know the thing is I thought
about you man because it was just like
literally everything you've been saying
about how you feel you know the invader
could be tweaked he's a little bit too
you know a little too extra so to speak
so I'm gonna give it to you because I
know that's something that definitely um
it was on your mind how did you feel
when you heard that yeah I mean that's
the type of stuff that I don't know if
people are gonna try that or if it's
gonna get used that much because again
what I would prefer and this is actually
closer to it cuz you can change some of
that stuff up I have it matches is one
thing and that's why I don't really care
about crucible if they ever in destiny
three put in custom games then we're
gonna start talking about some things
because that's the what they're kind of
teasing with the private matches for
game but prime as you can turn off the
invader vision or turn down the number
of play high-value targets that we're
running around little things like that
are actually gonna change the feeling of
the mode and I would just love to see
more even more depth on that it's
basically what I'm going for but just
the fact that those are there seems kind
of cool would I probably use it outside
of being like hey I just want to see
what it's like to shoot stuff or if you
want to test you know damage numbers on
games like you know in Prime Evils and
stuff like that you could do that type
of stuff but I mean honestly I don't
have a giant group of friends done I'm
gonna go run like hey let's go good
tournament I don't have that group
either you know to say well what about
you scary are you like a prime
that guy like hot does that interest you
so not traditionally and destiny one we
used to get a bunch of friends together
and just mess around and and sort of
private matches but it's never been it's
more of like drought content in my
opinion what I think Bungie was going
for here and I think it's a really smart
move is if I think they realize if
anything in destiny is balanced enough
to hit that eSports scene its Gambon run
a gambit or gambit prime in adding these
additional rules this is a classic Call
of Duty move being able to change
certain mechanics on the maps and of the
game mode and that sort of thing I think
I think this was kind of a hard Bank by
them to try to gain more of that
traction which they should that's a very
smart idea and if they can even get a
fraction of the competitive scene that
trials had back in destiny won that
that'll be huge for the game which of
course I want to happen so I'm glad this
is in the game especially with like
Rockstar doing the gambit competition
earlier in the year and I think I think
lucky and butt-wipe ended up winning
that and that sort of thing and so that
already has some notoriety to it so if
they can keep pushing it and maybe
trying to get some of that scene in
there I'm happy for it I think you know
I'm not probably gonna utilize it but I
think it's a fantastic move for sure
absolutely side note a Spartan hunter
that asked them who we all picking for
the allegiance question I hadn't got
there yet okay so gamma prime reckoning
to you two huge pillars of season The
Drifter honestly sound really cool like
definitely cool loop armor sets very
nice tease and then towards the later
part of the viaduct there's a quest
coming and guess what it's the gun that
everybody loves to hate thorns back it's
no shock to anyone obviously and I said
the foreign quest starts so potentially
over time do you guys think time gated
type situations oh yeah it seems like a
weekly thing for sure I think absolutely
I would as I would soon so I mean I
would with last word you know kind of
pretty kind of
at a certain time fragrance in decadence
that wouldn't be surprised I wouldn't be
surprised they kind of put it in a
Austin what's that exactly kind of did
like that um it was in war mind it was
the Polaris they oh yeah I go that route
but again they have to be careful
because the community has been very
vocal about time gaining so I got a see
you know how to handle it but uh let's
get to the gritty man thawing the
infamous dog you know so they asked to
extremes Garrow you know I believe shout
out to Steve Marathi I believe he asked
because he's a huge spawn fit right he's
like will I be able to to tap and walk
away either could I know there's a lot
they were to hold on to so there's a
chance it made not but they great they
were very reluctant to answer so uh
listen this is a very polarizing weapon
we all know the history of the thorn and
it's fun exciting a14 but there's the
other part dislike of me that takes okay
genomic turn like what's the dude is
wears off if if it's d1 potency thorn
scare oh help me out man we have too
many good hand cannons okay I'm gonna
say that okay I'm like is there another
class of weapon in this game I got
excited when people started realizing
that the thorns that they were using in
the last word quest were scour I feels I
was like oh I'm all for that man okay as
in terms of like in all reality I don't
know I think bungees learned a lot sense
vanilla destiny you know it obviously
took like nine months to balance and
that was the worst I mean it was the
best but it was the worst kind of thing
it was a very raw feeling crucible so I
I don't know man I just I know I'm
dreading like I really want to be
excited about it but I know the moment I
hop into crucible and I see just this
dart fly across the room hit me in the
face in my group my screen starts
flashing green I'm just gonna turn off
my xbox like I it's like it's like PTSD
get this out of here but what about make
the main things too we have to
understand right the Ovilus the obvious
thing is the damage over time yeah yes
and then we have it was a - cuz I
remember when they nerfed it in the two
things they talked about it in the
sandbox team was again no tea and the
fact that you had pulled you from the
fight you weren't able to regenerate
health as well as the enemy knowing your
position based on the DLT
your screen going you know green you
know say so it was just all these things
so again like Scarah said one would
think that in this new crucible meta you
know that Bungie has to come up with
something if they're going to bring this
thing back cuz it's kind of I don't want
to say it's like ice love ice breaker
level broken but it's it's it's
definitely up there it's something you
have to be very careful so I wonder how
they tackle it I'm so curious because in
my opinion cannot bring d1 potency for
like to be that it would get real
disgusting crisp underlord feel right
now but that's a great weapon in PvE
right nothing appeared not terrible in
PvP either people are running around
like Dave all these Thunder laws is out
here not the only thing to use but I
don't wanna say I love you isn't it so
yeah I love it too it's a it's a
fantastic way but yeah it's like well
okay here's the other thing though if
you have this level of like love-hate
diversity over but it is an iconic
weapon yeah can't come back weak saucy
they agree I agree with that has to
compete with Lunas yeah but I can't
destroy the game-mode you know and I
agree I mean they brought back there's
some weapon I was ready they brought
back a weapon for destiny one in it was
nowhere near as good I'll just use Jade
rabbit even though they that thing in
destiny wants to do yeah but I mean Jade
rabbit I think before the last patch
especially to me and I I got all I hate
for this but it was by far the war
exotic weapon oh yes needs you and I I
think that's a classic case of you can't
bring back an exotic he's exactly right
and in the underpowered because what's
the point of bringing it back at all
like especially something this iconic so
as much as I hate to say it has to be
powerful it has to compete with Lunas
but oh my goodness like thorn equals
cancer yeah I mean you guys are right in
the sense that if you're gonna bring
this back you're making a quest this gun
cannot be trash this gun cannot be
mediocre right but I just feel it has
the function different like it has to it
has to if you're gonna give the dot a in
that type of effect maybe you make you
some type of a skill weapon you know
what head shots or something but two
body shots walk away bro I make it more
focused on range to counteract the last
word because they're supposed to be kind
of like opposites so make it a slowest
by right hand cannon and still give it
the dot but give it make it max range or
something close to it that way it has an
edge over the Lunas over the last word
but that way because it's a slow rate of
fire you still have the ability to
balance that out from a sandbox
perspective that's that's my insight I'm
not a game designer excited no I like
this what you're saying is what Thorne
is almost the epitome I mean to be
throwing last word is the epitome of the
rundown weapon like I'm gonna run you
down if you're in close range you know
I'm saying yeah watch God where you
saying Thorne is that obviously where I
keep my distance you know saying maybe
make the rate of fire slower you know
I'm saying yeah it'd be interesting then
what makes sense lore wise right because
we know that's the counter gun so what
do you think he like I don't know
I'm literally it's it's gonna be a
delicate line I mean I'm gonna hear it's
like it can't be trash otherwise you
literally like it's sacrilege to the
or to this giant hype up the head of
last word the giant little cinematic all
those pieces it's gonna have some build
and you can't go through like a long
quest line and get this thing and be
like well this sucks it's not gonna
happen
you can't get the final weapon and be
like this is terrible about the Lord
because you have this dude talking to
the drifter when they're sitting at the
table back and forth like playing drift
or poker whatever it's called
yeah this dude with like the weird
hunter mask holding last word and
everybody's like who the hell's this guy
mmm was there not the Garter you think
they trying to set up some [ __ ] what's
it what's his name again
hey so they original this is a stranger
but they changed it it's the shadow the
shadow now the only reason I know that
shadows to some of you guys on Twitter
um sometimes when new releases or
content comes out for destiny they'll
release a like art pack and D tweeted
out for those who want content creators
you can download the pack and you've got
NPCs you've got the drifter the emissary
and the other one is the shadow that's
this guy so he is an NPC so there's
either gonna be some more some
discussion with this dude I don't know
if he's gonna talk but hey man the
drifter is sitting across from each
other at a table so something's going on
see that's really interesting cuz it
could be an NPC but what I just noticed
and I I'm you know that that's very
possible and you know shadow fits into
the shadows of yours and stuff but what
I just notice is like every piece of
armor he's wearing looks like a piece of
armor we can get which traditionally
isn't wyatt an npc wears you know see
that's what initially it was all
character right I thought yeah I did too
I thought arguing but the names fits in
with you know being like I said the
shadows of your and he clearly said that
he's not uh your anymore he he said that
to the the emissary of the nine and so
it makes sense if he's coming back to
hunt him down or I you know either way
look at it it could make sense educate
me Laura guys Oh
want to call my Holden yeah like we're
shin malphur in all this I'm um confused
he retired in the quest okay
so yeah yeah he gave us the last word
and he's like I'm out want long long
long story short it okay
okay I'm just curious with that okay cuz
so now and then the what's this whole
shadow guy's deal what's his business I
don't know if anybody knows yeah yeah
brand new is he do we have any Inklings
that he's and enemy of like we're we I
mean pointing a gun Adam so I probably
not completely on good terms yeah yeah
interesting shall desserts a year shin
malphur had enough he's like I'm out
here you go take over my man you take it
he's like I've killed enough people it's
an occasion good stuff here it'll be
interesting so yeah
giant divisive quest and gun we will see
how that one pairs out but I always
enjoyed thorne a lot more than last word
so you may hate me but I stuck with last
word so if I got to use one of them or
the easy button nature oh yeah so the
other thing that happens on the same day
we at the beginning of our allegiance
quest now they cover the allegiance
quest a little farther once we get to
the season of a drifter page or no
that's actually on the table right here
so the allegiance quest previously
forecast as the Joker's wild weekly
quests will invite you to choose between
and we're gonna answer your question if
you're still here hunter Bob between the
Vanguard and the drifter pick a side to
progress through the quest from their
perspective the pledges character-based
so if you have more than one character
you can play both sides but if you only
have one choose wisely well I guess so
here's the question what are you guys
going Mandy here's the question who's
not picking drifter for ya
that's where the story's gonna be right
like that's that's the interesting stuff
I you know I have three characters I
think most all of us probably do you
know I'll definitely swing by and it
since it's a weekly quest you know you
can do the drifter side and then
immediately do the Vanguard side week
per week but come on drifter has to be
the first sight hold on zero what you
mean you vanguard all the way at way to
me how dare you lie after the whole
thing we can't him man he's dead let it
let it go we ain't letting go with a
volleys reaction you know or non-action
zero loyalty can't be bought oh my
listen man I don't know what's a block
okay well i okay well you know the
renegade seems cooler i he's just I I
also don't trust him but that's where
the fun story's gonna be something's
gonna go wrong he gets a gun pointed at
him at some point so it can't be too bad
so let's see yeah let's pick the drifter
first see what happens and then circle
back around for the boring story you
know exactly okay anyone doing the van
go and I gotta go I mean that your
entire chat is that's what I did oh I
don't see I was like I mean I'm gonna do
both yeah but I was like part of me is
like my PvE type guy and stuff like that
I thought about Lina and Vanguard until
you said there's a volatile thing I'm
like yeah I got a go drifter first I
figure no no believe me I was like I was
like I'll talk disavow let's see what's
going on but yeah second character I'm
just gonna do both so I mean it's not
that big a deal for most of us and
honestly with we can talk about this now
as well the bounties for the character
boost so if you only do have one
character now is literally wait till
this comes out the best time to get a
second character up so you can see the
other side Oh cuz he's gonna have
bounties and you can get to 640 in life
couple hours crazy Cyrus let me get this
look that crazy yeah so what do you guys
think about these power surge back oh
this is what up wit like this is perfect
because again like scatter like I
literally made the transition to from
Xbox to PC okay
and um literally I made it right before
the launch of black Aubrey oh right so
put yourself in mommy's like I have all
this time we do a podcast together
you know we want to play testing
together I'm like yes a mini SPECT out a
crazy rig for me I'll put the money down
I'm here and then day one I'm like damn
I can't even touch that guy like I don't
feel bad I was level then I couldn't
touch it they want either because it was
so difficult no bro it was so crazy and
he just like and I'm seeing him struggle
and he's already at you know max light
at the time you know for the DLC and
stuff like that and we all we all know
the infamous stealth nerf we're not
stealth nerve but initial nerf of arm
one day nerf there one day nerf of the
forge because everyone we all admit the
onboarding with black armory was
terrible you don't say like that it just
wasn't accessible to the masses and you
had this content there that you know a
good chunk of the base you know post for
a second still couldn't touch so to see
this kind of stuff and again according
to the stream the way they said you
could knock this out in like an hour -
they just want you to do varied
activities you know it looks like a
public event or - like a couple of
bounties that's two pieces of 640 gear
like a strike and kill 50 enemies that's
2 pieces of gear that's like I don't
know 30 40 minutes and that's half
yourself like it's gonna go quick this
is what I'm talking about because again
the problem destiny in my opinion always
has is because of the DLCs you know it
is people that the hardcore gonna be so
far ahead and I have friends that I'll
see a new content from destiny like man
that looks cool can't wait to grab it
but then day one they can't even play
with us
right so dis is cool because here's the
thing he I got I got Gate Lord Atticus
coming he's gonna specie next week my
sister's coming he's got his PC already
you never saying like their height for
drifter so when I try to get them
to play now and they like dude I'm not
trying to do all those quests again I'm
not trying to you know power level all
the way up again like
they're almost they were willing to buy
a spark of light if Bungie offered it
and move us walking light did you just
pay for it did you like your backstab it
at the level of the dlc you know they
know yeah man so this is cool this is so
much needed great response in my opinion
to black armory and the feedback that
they received and I just can't wait
because my friends will actually be able
to play The Drifter you know I'm saying
when season if you have to Whitney and
I'm excited but what do you guys do
that's Carol oh yeah yep yeah all that I
mean you you pretty much hit it
perfectly I I'm not I you know I you
couldn't pay me to transition to
anything after I've cut I don't even
like checking my time on destiny to it's
kind of gross if you ask me like who two
minutes too much time but I I just
couldn't even imagine losing all that
bad for people who do are people who you
know took a break because I know black
army was very end game far me and people
yeah a lot of people might not like that
some people might be more of the sort of
what this expansion is going forward
it's more do this activity a couple of
times and get your power rather than do
it over and over and over and over and
over again to get this piece of loot or
whatever so that some people might have
checked out and you know this is a great
way to get them back into it but yeah
you know it's it this is this is Bungie
being confident and that is something I
love to see I feel it real quick it's
gotta pay the bills real quick shout the
Lord Philip Carlisle thank you so much
for the $10 super chat hey everyone
shout out to the RO my thoughts for
gambit they need a spectator mode where
you can bet glimmer or shards on
different things what are y'all fish
it'd be a fun tournament thing today for
sure
good way to gig master of course oh yeah
they should be that good to be honest
like low-key like the power surge that
that was the highlighted what if that
biggest highlight of the DLC for me I'll
better karate
like I was so excited to see that I
couldn't believe they did with a niche
dress there so I'm pumped man I'm bring
I'm bringing some PC boys through man so
we can have a crew yeah it's like
honestly it's just it gives the people
if you're like hey pick up destiny or
like hot on a grind well you do these
like eight bounties you'll be right next
to me oh it makes you especially like if
you get the Forsaken collection the only
question is I don't know if these are
for everyone or if they're for annual
pass or not I'm hoping they're for
everybody which would be a smart way to
do it it's the only thing I haven't seen
clarification or I may have missed it I
just don't know good for never mind it's
literally right here I thought I read it
well our Annual Pass holders the rest of
season drifter packs a new combat
specialties to embrace the new
challenges like season the forge the
journey will roll out over time but the
drifter has plenty of action for players
to experience if you if you think your
power is low and you want to get caught
up to the rest of the community see the
drifter to complete his new power surge
of bounties they're enough to bring you
up to 640 power so it is in the Annual
Pass section there but it's almost like
an appositive be for everybody yeah cuz
the weight the weight increases for
everyone I don't that's that's really
weird where they put that because that's
very ambiguous I agree yeah so it's like
I just want clarification if they're
smart about it it's gonna be for
everybody because everybody gets up to
700 anyway and if I'm gonna go play a
gambit match and you're gonna want to
have a chance in PvP you're gonna want
to be at least 640 because these people
are about to be 700 don't that's gonna
go fast but yeah if they're for
everybody then you know they crushed it
that's the only piece I got that was the
only thing I saw yeah so those are
actually gonna be really cool nice way
to jump up and see what the heck is
going on so before we get to some of the
everybody stuff we got one more thing to
talk about invitations of the nine so
how much have you seen about this once
Carol so I I know you get something and
then you take it dessert alright would
start dessert and then you do it and
then he gives you another bounty and
that's what I got a long time quest that
I know that - mm-hmm
yeah yeah so individual invitations of
the nine
once upon a time referred to as the ZURB
bounties which is at least they're gonna
give something to do on its little tree
posts and hanger platforms and stuff
like that will be an exploration of the
nine in the mysterious place in the
universe the path begins with zero on
Friday March 15th I'm literally out of
time so I'm gonna lug my computer up
where I'm going
Oh socks you had two dogs one computer
and a partridge in a pear tree annual
pass owners will be able to pick up an
invitation of the nine from xur once the
objectives are completed it will be
transformed into a bounded called into
the unknown these will be available to
complete once per character similar to
the boundaries you get at the beginning
of forsaken for completing an activity
with a full gear set mmm so just as if
you had to go finish a strike with a
full vanguard set week over week for
nine weeks you'll collect new lore and
powerful rewards so the important thing
for me here is you know we can do the
Queen's throne over and over again week
after week and get that new war every
three weeks or whatever but the rewards
aren't exclusive to that so the only
reason we have to do is for the war I
would really like for there to be an
armor set exclusive to this where you
have to complete these bounties and you
get it and it I don't care if they just
repurpose the trials of the nine armor
set I mean he'll the the Charles of the
nine season two armor set is my favorite
armor set of all time especially a
million it's beautiful with the
ornaments so if if we could get those
back through this
give me incentive to do them is what I'm
saying war is awesome that's that's
great but if you're offering powerful
rewards make sure they matter that's
that's what I got yeah Cognito thank you
sir yeah this is interesting I mean we
we definitely um you know talked about
it again this was known as the you know
deserve bounty kind of thing and we all
feel that he really had no function that
outside of you know me being a new one
PC and looking forward to him every week
cuz I had no exotics coming over oh you
know he really doesn't have any
functionality for the hardcore so yeah
let's put him to use you know I'm saying
I'm cool that I'm in agreement with Kara
what he said in reference to the gear
set and stuff like that I want to
reserve judgment only until I see this
stuff I want to see it you know I'm
saying and it's one of those things I
mean it sounds cool but unfortunately
xur doesn't have the greatest reputation
when anything they've done over the past
you know he's been through so many
iterations they've tried so many things
nightfall stuff and you know you know
the poor guy just needs a legit job that
is worthwhile hashtag it's her job it's
their job you know make them useful you
know so we'll see it in theory sounds
good I do like the connection with the
nine I love that stuff I love him
separate I love nine separated from my
shredder so this is all good you know
about the minded I'll shut up the set
for an inch app by the way welcome again
twitch prime sub for five months thank
you sir
very much appreciate and welcome to
evening um yeah me too as well we've got
dessert having something to do I mean as
I'm literally given zero hard time
you're Chad he's up there he's like
those leaves and necess don't pluck
themselves Amelie yeah they're literally
trimming trees that is what's going on
the gardener to trim the tree trimmer he
stands in his little tree unnecessary go
up there staying on the tree talk to him
getting shot by vechs down on the ground
they're like I can get shot how come he
can get shot apparently he's got
tentacle face he can't even get damaged
anyway he's we don't know what he is but
honestly if he's an agent of the nine
and we get to know more about the nine
this has been five years in the making
and finally we get to know more about
all the where he comes from
finally so I still want to know why she
looks like the well she's the emissary
of the nine he is an agent of the nine
we still don't know what to hell the
nine are so yo cuz she looks a very
different than tentacle face and they're
still not related to them so maybe we'll
get to see a little bit more who knows
still very curious still probably not
the space story dose that's probably d3
so yeah in case you haven't realized
we've been unpacking a lot of stuff here
but there's more
we have something called Ark week now
before I say anything because I put my
video out there I'm sure you did yours
as well
I want to get Cognito first and then
scarole I want your guy's ideas what the
hell this is no literally you asking the
wrong person
I literally don't know what this is I
was like we all just gonna whip out
thunderlord's and Ark week like I'm not
Chad we just I just don't know what it
is I'm trying to be help me scare I
don't know that this is this is really
difficult because you know we're so or
week or is void week of why arcs
specifically what is this shaming it's
just so odd because like oh maybe all
our quest more damaged wait but then you
think about heroic strikes and daily
story missions once every three weeks
that already happens or it actually is
on the daily rotation now it's it's the
things last for a week okay yeah so they
still do then okay cool yeah so they're
on a weekly rotation anyways so this
thing has to be something special you
can't can you just celebrate a type of
life that's so white what is happening
are you gonna be walking around the
tower and and your rain are we gonna get
just like a boulder aided by lightning
or won't like what's gonna happen here
what is this I don't know I hope it's
really cool I hope it's you know there's
so many cool I don't want to get too
excited but it has to be something cool
I can we get like a an arc or effect if
we do something during this week
discount is a live event are there going
to be exclusive triumphs is just just
like a weird you know I don't want to
draw too many comparisons but maybe this
is like Destiny's mini version of a
cataclysm from anthem or something like
something odd has to happen for them to
to draw this much focus my biggest fear
is it's gonna be something really dumb
I'm really hoping it's crazy though I
just don't know are everywhere and you
go into a raid and you have a sense I'm
like but I'm with you I'm like what what
what are you doing for
one that was the first thing or I
tweeted out so either Deidre Cosmo or
Dylan one of those I was like okay so
first off what is this and two what is
it we're a solar would be like yeah why
are those not on the table
first off either they're gonna be in the
next season and this is like a trial or
something weird but also I'm like okay
as you said we have it on you can put a
singe on a nightfall okay you know Ark
have on a three week rotation so what
are you missing like gambit and raids
and crucible I mean if you're just gonna
have Ark do more damage everywhere it's
just everybody's gonna use the ark
weapons for a week but it still seems
yeah I don't I don't have to be
something more than that
see I was thinking modifiers first as
well but it's just that just y-yeah it
seems kind of useless
it's almost for like it's like Ark
weapon Appreciation Week ladies gonna
everyone's gonna have like the coil out
this bundle or like it's just so strange
it's very strange and I just want to
backtrack to one thing that we haven't
seen on this odd list I know we still
got one more to go for April 16th but um
I was a little surprised maybe not too
much that it wouldn't be in The Drifter
but what do you guys feel about faction
rally you know like what where we at
with that like what what's going on like
you know we I mean we we know it's not
completely eliminated like how you don't
like shout out to lord king currently
it's in the bushes on fire I really
don't know honestly because faction
rallies the and they also haven't
mentioned the catalyst with faction or
Ally's yeah get ever the um what you
call at the graviton Lance catalyst
that's what arc week is maybe we get all
the catalyst for all of our exotics that
are have art burns mmm
maybe I'm just I'm trying to think
outside the box I know there's a zero
percent chance that that happens but you
know it has to be something creative
like that it's just so weird
yeah it's just random Oh random and
weird
I completely agree alright I'm now like
you know very excited to know what the
hell it is but I'm also temple an
expectation because when I see
free to all players again I'm like mm
you know how cool is it really gonna be
you know they so again temper and
expectation we'll see yeah I mean if
they just Electrify the tower they'd be
cool really cool be a giant wave I'd be
fun with that like I said if there is a
one in a hundred chance that every time
you took a step in PvE got just
obliterated by a lightning bolt I'd be
fine with that cause I that's an anthem
right there by the way yeah
lightning strikes coming down to
weather's going together you're like
where is it where is it and you're like
crap I just got smashed
alright zero has some theories okay what
if there's gonna be a new live event
with a special weapon as a reward and
that element changes so maybe your soul
a week down the road and so on like
let's say there's a really neat arc
exotic that's new and it's available
during this week through a special quest
or something but yeah really limit and
exotic for oh yeah that doesn't that's
not like a very Bungie thing though you
know it's interesting it's interesting
that you guys got me so curious about
like what yeah I did you know for all we
know this could be the returning of
faction rallies and instead of just you
farming randomly and stuff it's which
faction can get the most art kills in a
week you know like that actually I mean
it's the best thing I've heard between
all of us yet yeah it could it just the
thing is it could literally be
everything what if Art Week is a
celebration of arc so you can't use it
and you have to use everything but arc
for that week you know I could literally
be anything it's it's it's so it's so
odd yeah very much in the arbitrary
space yes to say the absolute least and
I love how they had didn't even like
talked about it anywhere mention
anything it's just like it's pop up out
of no way that's the you know that's
what they were going for though it's a
talking point for sure
they're like going over stuff I'm like
is it anywhere no yeah just just so
weird I don't know I'm excited for your
solar week you know shout out the solar
week unless you like Nighthawks out
there just yeah for real
and yeah and then to wrap it up the
revelry which is April 16th and May six
so I think three weeks is how long
that'll be free to all players I will
say shout out to the art team by the way
because they always have to come up with
a new color scheme and once again they
did and it looks like it's own thing I
don't know how they keep doing it I feel
like they would have run out of colors
by now but once again they have its own
thing I can't quite tell too much of
what this is gonna be there is one T's
in the video of a dude wearing a jacket
and it says srl on his jacket and other
people wondering if it's even related to
this or not woah he's wearing an srl
jacket it could be an old one and it may
mean nothing but I was like don't wear
the jacket in the video if you're not
gonna do anything with it
hey we know it has something to do with
the infinite force right like there to
confirm that really yeah they said they
said that we're going I think I think
it's on this page right here oh oh
Cyrus is parking what do you say for the
floors okay you go maybe try to look
around this page I believe it says and
wait and the live event will even take
us back into a familiar forest and then
if you look in the by dog while they're
talking about it they're clearly in the
infinite forest I do remember that kind
of in the viaduct um yeah or I
definitely read that I don't know where
it was you brought like you've got oh
okay wait I think was that it got her go
go up a little bit
don't let me sorry let me go to this
page myself this might be a little bit
less fresh like I try and zoom in as
much as I can be oh no we can't see it
also let me let me let me just jump
there real quick let me try to find it I
believe I remember specifically reading
that it will be in the infinite forest
I just don't know alright let's keep
talking and only if I find it I'll come
back yeah I mean I'm looking at red and
they're even like it's the spring of in
something like the dawning and
somebody's like related to the infinite
forest - and I think just because you
said that piece and the violet oh here
it here it is here it is here it is it's
an it's the very very first paragraph on
the page you're on the first spring
event for destiny will reveal a familiar
forest in bloom with
resolute interesting and and if you go
in the Vidocq while they are wearing the
armor they are in they are definitely in
the infinite force just real quick does
this will this program pick up my
desktop noise or is it okay well I'm not
I'm trying to get it not to do that oh
yeah okay yeah let me know if you guys
can hear this I'm trying to I want to
try to find the time see the video let
me know and then I switch over to you as
well just let me know all I can pull it
up yeah I'll just some of the time soon
oh yeah sounds good but yeah that pretty
much covers the general calendar and
then we've got a few updates to just the
overall calendar obviously season the
forage is done so for March and May
season The Drifter yeah but private
matches power increased new vanity
rewards new rank rewards triumph book
exotic quest now there's an exotic quest
for everybody there's an exotic quest
with the annual pass which one do you
guys think is thorn annual pass is
probably thorn last word what yeah last
word was annual pass right yeah yeah off
their DLC cash you go get the timestamp
717 in the bye dog all right cool hold
that thought
there's a couple shots you girl yeah so
that's wait wait not that not yet go go
right past that there you go yeah
definitely the infinite forest and
they're wearing the armor sets and this
is where they're talking about it yeah
so I mean again the color scheme looks
like I don't know the blue the L of the
green it's definitely its own color
scheme yeah so revelry and then that's
literally if they're like the revelry
and then week two they talk about thorn
but I can't tell if those are specific
weapons to it though I think those are
the gambe weapons yeah they look like
that's born up there in the top yeah
he's got like cloth padding gear on it's
a gun well yeah definitely spring event
whatever that is but I think you alright
it's definitely somewhere in the
infinite forest with that worries me
though like how similar is it going to
be once again at a haunted forest I've
a lot of faith and Bungie to make this
their own thing but it's the it's the
uncertainty in between that sometimes
can play with your mind a little bit
yeah yeah I'm just curious Lorelei's
like you know what is that what is the
revelry like what is this about like
yeah absolutely
I'm very curious with they need a mess
with Miley Cyrus man I want you know
back looking like we from Woodstock and
you know all the stuff stuff going on no
disrespect I love my Egyptian garb and
you're good
I got a see you know say what I love
that the assets are being used because
y'all you know we mean he have talked at
nauseam about how mercury is underused
you know I'm saying and it's just a big
roundabout way Ju sparrow on so uh yeah
let's see how do you infinite forest
goals you know saying and see what they
do it you know I've told Horror Story
was cool you know the whole you know
when he did it for the what you call an
event what's the name in event I'm
blanking on the name of it now haunted
forest
all right yeah I thought that was cool
you know I'm saying I had no problem
with that a little nice little twist on
it but uh yeah I'm very very curious
about this revelry thing so what is it
what is that whole thing mean do you
guys I still want to know the word
revelry means this will make you laugh
live lively a noisy festivities
especially when those involved drinking
a large amount of alcohol really that's
the definition of revelry all right
let's go get smashed in the infinite
force yet sounds like a spring event to
me I want to buy The Drifter about four
shots and get some stories so you guys
think Florin will be Annual Pass then
we've got an exotic quest that they've
been shinned absolutely nothing about
yet gotta be it has to be a new exotic
give us new exotics I hope so I really
want new stuff I'm kind of getting tired
old stuff yep um that that rolls rumor
grows handcannon
that might be the last season from what
I heard from that leak a long time ago
man enough with the hand cannon thank
you
where is it where's my love for exotics
pulsus we haven't had in exotic pulse or
an exotic scout since vanilla if I'm not
mistaken yeah seriously it's like there
are other gun types Bungie come on eat
you guys might be mad didn't know then
we hear confirmation that Hawk who might
be coming back well if the I love I love
Hawkman so that's the one I'll be like
oh if they came back but keep in mind
there is a giant week right before
season two the forge where people said
that ADA's name was gaunt and she was a
dude so I I take all of these with a
giant grain of salt now and Plus that
same week said the icebreakers coming
back and the day that happens is the day
I I'm out of here no I'm never touching
crucible again so I don't put any any
retail in any of those I'm hoping it's a
new exotic pulse or Scout preferably
pulse but we'll have to see you know
yeah so iron banner of course will be
their arc week we still don't have a
freaking clue what that is revelry
spring event for Annual Pass invitations
of the nine The Reckoning gambit prime
its weapons and gear private matches in
the allegiance quest now I know we kind
of saw this picture before and they kind
of talked about Joker's wild but how do
you guys feel now having seen the full
viaduct the farther deeper breakdown how
you guys feel about this season though
what do you feel like where are you
where you at like I said I was so I I'm
the type of player that loves farming
things over and over again you guys you
mentioned my reactions that's because I
love sitting there doing the same thing
and then that there reward of getting
something after the 100th time it's it
is the greatest feeling in the world to
me so coming off season of the forge I
wasn't very excited for this season
however now that I see all this stuff I
mean it looks like so much fun I'm
equally as excited as I was for the
season of The Forge which I think in
itself is a huge accomplishment for
Bungie I'm very excited I easily at 8 or
9 out of 10 of excitement for this
season for sure you definitely see why
anthem speaks to you for sure yes you're
going for that min/max and be like oh I
got the new
I got the new hotness sweet yeah what
about you Cognito how you feeling um
initially I'll be honest when I saw the
video
I was like okay because again I came in
to full disclosure like Forge wasn't the
greatest for me you know I'm saying I
told you about my onboarding issue and
then when I finally got to go in and
like still gotta get his an ami done and
stuff like that I'm towards the tail in
but it wasn't terrible content it's just
like it's just a different approach from
what I'm used to right so you know and I
thought I just was disappointed lore
wise especially right my whole thing and
then we launched it and you know it's
like oh yeah go to this chick downstairs
in the tower like what it was just like
you know Oh speak to Spyder then this
random persons in your basement and you
go talk to them and it's all been there
all this time and okay fine but you know
so at the end of the day I felt this is
them kind of finding a way experimenting
you know me and EE we've talked about
this obviously with the other games out
right now the vision and anthem you know
I'll be honest like I had dream low
expectations coming in for the drift II
you know I just initially thought it was
gonna be a gambit mode here and there
you know one other thing and the thing
off the back that I like that it seems
to be some more in this right and that
to me is the hook that's initially
welcomed EMI okay he's sitting there
he's talking to the shadow person he's
talking to the emissary of the nine okay
what's going on and then as we get more
information I'm like okay this is a
little bit more meaty than I thought it
was you know obviously we know there was
no raid you know I'm saying I knew no
raid that's another thing I was worried
about how how hefty is this DLC gonna be
so you know now that we start to look at
it I think for me what changed me in the
direction of Skaro with excitement is
watching the stream he has a lot they're
just so good like you know know for sure
I mean I mix it you guys are getting me
hyped for it
please man those guys out to destiny
Gary you know those guys CJ and they had
a Dijon and Larson and crew
and when they broke it down then I was
getting excited because I didn't realize
you know the perk sets and the armor
sets and the rolls in the red pants the
Raby invaders just like okay I'm more
excited about the quality of life stuff
in the lore actually more than the
content don't get me wrong
reckoning sounds dope you know I'm
saying like gambit prime sounds amazing
you know all this stuff sounds cool but
I'm actually happy about the quality of
life stuff and that power surge brownies
and all that so yeah like this is a
pleasant surprise for me I I'm still a
little cautious because I want to see
that once we stuck him up we're all
hardcore on this panel right yeah once
we blaze out because you know we all
gonna blaze out we're gonna hit the
ground running we're gonna be in that
gamma prime know talking about gaming
right yeah you just set it up I don't
even do that stuff you know curious to
see that gameplay loop how long it
sustains us you know and this new way of
handling content so it went up right now
I'm in the the 7 8 Rin I want to give it
to 8 yet I'm in that 7 range now before
I came in as a 4 or 5 I'm up to a 7 and
now just gonna play it and then after we
get you know entrenched in it then I'll
give you you know more of a feel but
what about you he not at you know the
Fed Aqsa here and information is
starting to leak you know where are you
at with us is it season to drift it
right now
so I was like you I mean we both had
been talking about us like this I in my
head and actually sadly I was hoping
between anthem and division and
everything else going on the game but
would actually be kind of a tamer season
yes mostly just cuz there's not enough
time to do everything
yes now I'm like crap jazz for me it's
the reckoning that actually has me the
most appealing ambit if I can fund yes
gambit for me is I played enough solo
and
have a regular group where the solo
playing gambit is tough but the
reckoning piece the PvE the horde mode
that and then like the invitations class
the allegiance quests those pieces but
the reckoning horde I want to see what
that loop feels like that's the one that
had because that's the one thing on all
of this
we had no idea that was coming outside
of Ark week which I still don't have a
damn clue this is anything the reckoning
was there like ace up the sleeve that
they dropped and said oh by the way it's
not just gambit and I was like okay now
you got me an intrigued that was the one
that turned me to be like oh that turned
me up as well I'm like yeah I'm kinda
like you I'm like I'm not about a seven
now I want to see how the feel the loop
is like how much game but do I have to
play to go spend I mean reckoning I know
you can I don't know if you can they
said you can stay in reckoning as long
as you want but I don't know you have to
if you have to have a sense to like
start your queue like you could it
sounds like you can spend two hours in
there if you want to like trying to get
something to work or practicing or
something like that but I don't know as
you said what the loop is like quick The
Sims come what the grind is gonna be
like now my only issue with this is that
the armour you get in reckoning doesn't
help you in reckoning yep yeah it helps
you in gambit which is cool to go back
and do that but again that set bonus and
these sets don't help you anywhere else
you could wear the set all the time
you're still getting your normal perks
and stuff like that but again this is a
tiny tiny piece that we need more right
right yeah I mean wow thank you Phillip
Carter you find out so good chat he says
I think it's gonna be something that we
don't expect it may not have anything to
do with any arc related thing are you
talking about the earthquake arc week
okay shout out Phillip Carla that's my
guy right there van good guy yeah this
is it's interesting man like I said I
mean I'm getting close to where's Kara
getting close you know say I need to
play it I didn't need more because again
season at a forge let eat you know you
said it best it's with the other games
being out anthem and division I already
mentally in my mind assumed this is just
gonna be like right so destiny is gonna
be a very casual thing at this point
while I do the
two games and then I'm like dammit
destiny every time like this is like I'm
gonna play this so now I'm like three
loaded shooters here we go I'm gonna no
life I'm like literally gonna have no
life like this was the it's a fun time
as a destiny fan but I was like any type
of content creator or you know you just
like how am I gonna find the time to do
yeah you know we've been talking a long
time we got a little bit of show left
from the other two but um yeah man like
destiny surprise me I didn't expect I'm
like this is gonna be light we gonna get
to gambit mats and they gonna call it a
day you know get good though I knew dawn
was coming back but yeah we were gonna
get this level of beef funny anything
was gonna be beefy so you know we'll see
shot the caddy Rex warframes better than
destiny there but thank you for your
contribution sir yeah so there's one
more piece and without saying too much
on it we have the final season but I
want Luke Smith to say this part because
okay seriously before I even say
anything
shout outs ass Carol I need your face
game for that reaction so we gonna make
that happen at some point but the audio
may not come through as well on ILP but
if you guys are watching on twitch I'm
just gonna let this thing play crank up
the volume to max and just listen to the
words
don't know if we can hear anything yeah
we getting then oh you guys can't hear
anything
actually hold on hold on right I was
like I was like when they give it a
second me I'll put it back hold on let
me see if I can get you guys to you know
hang on says what then what are you it
might be a twitch exclusive okay fine
I'll tell you guys this go to the
viaduct and go 750 will hit play at the
same time okay make sure everybody's
ready three wait no actually more than
three okay okay everybody ready go [ __ ]
now I just want to make sure I'm trying
to see is my sound not coming out David
wouldn't hear mine
yeah buddy Kenny goes at this I would
dance a the damn thing anyway okay hold
on yeah
giant anti-climactic start 3 2 1 go you
had to tell my the LP jet what happened
don't worry guys we'll suffer in silence
together slow framerate no sound don't
you worry
all right so I LP and that's one of
those things we got to figure out for
the podcast for you guys to actually uh
just kind of get the same stream so
we'll work on that piece later Luke
Smith
I know scary you're about to lose your
mind so say it it sold over del voice of
give a bribe dude it's after oh my gosh
I'm so excited guys I'm so excited this
is going to be the best season of all
time fact it's their use can't so I just
mentioned how I love farming the one
thing I love more than farming is
secrets okay the the reason my channel
started to blow up was the whisper of
the worm I was one of the first fire
teams I think I was like I don't want to
I hate making like broad statements like
this I think I was like the first person
like actually streaming looking for it
because I was on destiny sub right like
the secrets the second that post got
posted and I was like oh I got to do
this I will have this thing I've been a
huge call of duty zombies fan like like
Easter eggs for the longest time and it
this is what they're doing and I am so
excited I am so incredibly excited I'm
about to lose my mind
break it down
eat [ __ ] my dad is like what's going on
so basically what we've got is Luke
Smith talking about for one he dropped
the name that I didn't even expect
because
season of the blank redacted or whatever
you want to call it for the longest time
season of opulence now once again
bringing up the joys of definitions
opulence is great wealth or luxurious
nastain gloriousness sumptuousness
lavishness richness luxury luxury and
splendor magnificence Granger a scroll
going very weird and it's all in the
Leviathan yo because I mean that's what
that is
big boys live in the life of luxury so
what one of my biggest takeaways was for
one Luke Smith being in it because he's
always usually few and far between in
these things
and to he was saying we're trying to
figure out where we take this game
hey I forget the words cuz he just said
him but it was like basically it's now
Bungie owns this thing
yeah Bungie controlled destiny bunch of
control destiny yep yeah and it's like
and to see what that looks like
mm-hmm and then you have the teasers
from the other guys did you go out the
thing after this no like wait there's
the thing after this and all of those
pieces were just the teases of stuff to
come yeah so cease the ambulance we've
had the calendar out there for a while
not a lot of changes we know the six
placement match main activity is
different than the raid which will be
cool
solstice of Heroes one more exotic quest
for everybody that stuff's gonna be
there mm-hmm but from that video looks
like you've got the raid which will be
of course what everybody waits for six
player match made activity which looks
like they may have teased but if it's
all in the Leviathan we'll see right but
what I want to know Cognito from you and
I think we kind of talked about it
before I want each of you just reactions
from like what Luke Smith is talking
about what are you guys feelings about
the future after just his little little
little sound bite at the end I think I'm
glad you mention that because I caught
that too my eyebrows raised and you know
Luke's been on the front line and um you
know especially during the whole
transition between the Activision and
Bungie split and you know salute to him
because I was so proud of him
when he in in theory kind of stood up to
activision when you know the comments
were hey you know we're not happy with
the performance of yeah Bungie's destiny
and you know luke stuff you got on the
front line and it's not easy to do your
bosses you know that's your boss that
one at one point so you know you're just
like look we are extremely proud of
forsaken you know and I think it just
really resonated with the hardcore based
of fans and to see him come out and
again we don't see him much but to see
him be a part of this vid I can stay a
statement like hey I'm excited to see
what a Bungie LED destiny could be those
are the words we need to hear right
though that's what we that's gonna
instill confidence in the base that's
gonna get us all riled up it's gonna
galvanize us you know and um you know we
got the name draft you know the season
of
they exert whoo you know and we need you
know we've talked about it before like
we need closure with the Calais story we
need closure we need to know what's
going on you know kind of thing and then
you know even after the season of
opulence right that to me is even the
more exciting time because you know
they're free from the shackles of the
Activision release schedule they're free
from they have full creative control on
what they want to do and literally their
own destiny so this point it just comes
down to you know it could be it's it's
exciting it's exciting to see them have
you know creative control and I am very
curious to see where this thing goes and
you know I'm gonna bring this to scare
oh I was gonna say like um you know me
Andy boxes has had discussions I'm glad
you're asking this because I was worried
about too that's how we know and it's
like yeah man like I was gonna bring it
to you because it's like the way I see
it is you know this is uncharted
territory right yeah so the question I
have for you scaring again many bunsen
have debated back and forth we have kind
of different schools of thoughts on what
should happen but like from a activision
you know less controlled destiny
- now Bungie full control how do you
think they should handle destiny
postseason of opulence should they
return to the normal schedule the
Activision so to speak of a big Content
drum almost a comment level taking king
level forsaken level DLC September ish
or that's kind of about what I was
thinking and they or kind of do what he
is thinking when he is like look you
know take your time you know it's okay
like you can go away and then all guns
are blazing for d3 maybe in 2020
you know so where are you at with the
current state of destiny as far as the
future postseason of opulence alright so
I like this question a lot I have this
discussion with a lot of people even
before the activision thing was
announced because obviously this year
with the annual pass has been incredibly
different
and incredibly more consistent than any
time in Destiny's history I so I
actually think it's a mix so I think the
Destiny three-team I think they're there
in hot
you know they're there in the studio
they're working alright they're they're
completely separate they're doing
whatever if if it was a perfect for me
and we get this is where you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna make some assumptions
here and that it needs to be understood
that there's some assumptions but what I
want them to do in September I'm
assuming there's already a dlc in the
works I want it to be for say concise
and I want it to be about Sabbath oon I
wanted to wrap up that entire that
entire storyline then or and and start
to tease the truck the arrival of the
triangle ships and and get that into get
into gear for destiny three I think
that's gonna be the main destiny three
storyline then I want an entire new year
so exactly what we have right now again
so another annual pass I am an
incredibly big fan of this there hasn't
I mean we've had we've had one drought
in in black armory and it was two weeks
on that is incredible that is just
unbelievable that means that we went
from warmind all the way till two weeks
ago with content every single week or at
least every other week or something
always to do something to grind for her
I did you know because I I grind for the
titles and the triumphs and I have every
catalyst and that sort of thing I'm a
hardcore I get everything kind of guy I
ran out of stuff to do
two weeks ago know that that is that's
almost an entire year of content that is
incredible I want them to continue on
with this one big DLC Annual Pass thing
the only reason I really want one big
DLC a year it's because with the Annual
Pass we don't get a enough story I think
to justify some of the big big people
you know if they would have tried to do
the Dreaming City storyline driven all
that in in an annual pass expansion like
black armory or something I don't think
it would have done it justice I don't
think it'll do triangle ships justice I
don't think it'll do Sabbath injustice
these big names they need their own
cinematic campaigns create everything
else
give me content give me more I don't I
don't care about campaigns for for Forge
I don't care about it for drifter give
me stories in terms of activities and
these quests give me stuff to farm for
get this is perfect what we have here
one giant comet sized dlc in september
another year of Annual Pass bring on
destiny three keep that same welcome
assuming that they're still because III
know everyone's like you know don't do
destiny three keep everything in destiny
two and I you know i-i've already come
in terms with the fact we're gonna have
to start over again and and assuming
that we have to keep the same exact
content rotation for destiny three and I
think if they keep do it one upping
themselves every year
I think the destiny will will go down in
the history books for sure I'm gonna
play devil's advocate because I know
where he is thinking again I think I
know what he's thinking this time what
about a give you a counterpoint what
about you know the whole thought process
again this is this is uncharted
territory also besides the fact they're
free from Activision there is serious
competition out here right we're gonna
talk about anthem we all feel how we
feel about it but it's here you know
saying and then you know we have
division that's coming in March and you
know I know it's not for everybody I
know it's a different kind of it's not
space magic you know I get it
but we have to admit that uh even with
Division one with the feelings towards
the end if you remember the first three
months the player base plummeted right
yeah it plummeted you know saying and I
remember the Destiny player blaze that
was I think it was right I'm gonna say
post taken king is when Division one
launched maybe like in spring or
something and destiny was still kind of
finding itself cuz there was a long
drought post taking yet and um you know
division came on like gangbusters and I
remember a lot of streamers and half
nearly 80% of my friend list including
destiny players leaving destiny for
division now we do know that they have a
lot of content we'll get into that you
know a little bit you know as far as
what's coming you know the question is
on the plate that was Africa because of
the climate is this competitive space
like do you think it's okay for them to
kind of like
after opulence cook and just all
guns-a-blazing so that d3 is the best
possible content it can be I don't think
that would be a good move I think what
they're doing here I I think they're
using Season Of The Drifter purposely as
a buffer
you know it's content that not
everyone's going to be interested in I
think they put it here very
strategically because they knew at least
anthem was coming out at this time I
don't know if at the time that they were
developing it if division would have
been announced yet but I think this was
purposely here as a buffer and that's
why they're hitting us hard with
opulence I don't think they can afford a
another dry season like taking King that
nearly killed us I understand you know
they needed to develop the game if they
need to delay it another year do it but
I think if we have a forsaken size DLC
or hell even like taking Kings
you know something smaller I think that
is necessary to bridge that gap because
you know the only thing worse than
responding poorly is not responding at
all so one really think if well you know
I I was originally thinking anthem was
going to be a huge competition it
doesn't seem like it's going to be that
big now division it's very centralized
you know it has a very polarized fan
base I think the thing that they really
need to be worried about
especially with gearbox confirming that
they're going to PAX East this year is
Borderlands board the next Borderlands
and so I think is gonna be the only
thing that can touch the Titan that is
destiny they're gonna take they're gonna
take hitting you know player base hits
every now again that's the nature of a
live game they're gonna come back the
next big expansion a game like border I
mean people still play Borderlands 2
every day to this day and it's 7 years
old like you know that that that's
that's what I'm scared for in terms of
the destiny of what which I'm looking
forward to it too don't get me wrong but
as a destiny fan I don't fear division
taking away player base I don't fear
anthem taking away player base at least
not for an extended period of time I
think they're fine releasing especially
with how quickly they've been releasing
content and keep in mind you know season
of opulence is almost entirely to my
understanding Vicarious Visions
working on anyway so they've had that
their entire life seem freed up for the
next DLC
if I understand the inner workings
correctly so I think they're in a really
good good place right now I think though
I think they'll roll these punches from
the division anthem we're gonna roll
right off of destiny it's gonna be
really good interesting I gotta give it
to e because I don't eat shelving it fit
right now you're good she's ready for
attack okay I'm not attacking anything
No
so my opinion on this whole thing just
because there's usually towards the end
of each one of these is I'm kinda with
you guys on the fact that it is nice to
have the content but what we've got
people that have been burned by destiny
won and fallen off people burned my
destiny to hardcore in year one even
though one of my like closest gaming
friends like did not get war mind
because Osiris was so bad and I couldn't
tell him to get it so you people that
have been burned twice and then if you
keep it as destiny to selling to new
people for a second did a lot for second
did a lot to bring it back but even
Activision said it's piece of like you
know what sales weren't all of what it
was expecting now their numbers are
scurry we know they're you know making
gobs and gobs but we have the Nettie's
hundred million that came in you had
that as an incentive but you also have
now shout at the hawk law saying for
Bungie to get away from Activision they
paid about a hundred and sixty million
dollars in a couple different ways to
break away from Activision and owned
their rights so I was like after eating
that I was like hearing that from oak I
know
Cognito sitting there grinning from ear
to ear he's like you got to be able to
pay for it which is one thing and that's
where I was like I don't know if the
Nettie's made it possible I don't know
the cash in their coffers and my big
worry is every release of destiny has
been rushed either destiny one revamp
like 16 months before and basically not
having a great story finally come
together and taking king then you had
destiny to which I don't know if I got
remade again but they broke so many
things and again this pressure the fact
that they finally have the option not to
be on a September schedule yep
gives them flexibility that they've
never had before and my big piece is
that I would rather them take the time
to build what they need to whether it's
not on this perfect release schedule
what if they did a taking King style
thing but what if it's in I don't know
February or March or I think you need
something in between a supplement I
don't know like they're I don't think
the way especially with how these are
leaking out content you know week after
week I don't think they're built their
survivors you're out like that so what
do you think if they release like a d3
and they're like hey this is like the
rumors about the RPGs they take the time
to build on it and they can come back
and they go brand new consoles d3 my
only worry is if they don't do that
right the the game is completely done
whatever they do an X I agree I that's
who I worry is like the give-and-take
between the two and I know you said like
what Vicarious Visions or hi moon is
finishing up opulence which is when they
are supposed to be separate we know D
whatever you know if something is
September it probably was in the works
but it was like they have the
flexibility not to and I'm just like
I've worried on I don't know if they can
hit four seconds mark again if they do
taking King and then a rise of iron
that's still a very different level of
content difference and if they do
forsaken and rise of iron - that doesn't
live up to the Sabbath on that you want
is that gonna hurt people enough that
even like d3 won't matter or but yeah as
you said I mean like the the cadence
makes sense finish savathun if you can
have that type of level finish that
story and then do the space doritos
triangle ships that's I heard chef Tico
him space Doritos ones that I laughed my
butt off but yeah the triangle ships
like that makes sense for d3 I just
don't know if she's the darkness or
whatever or if they're separate but it's
just my worry of getting a piece of
content that is rushed because
everything has felt rushed and they
finally have the flexibility I'd like to
see them so again I'm torn on the
financial and like the cadence side but
again me like if they took some time off
or like had some smaller pieces what if
they did like a year's worth of annual
pass and not a four second piece but
then d3 was like amazing
yeah I think so if instead of a four
second piece they just did four annual
pass things I think that would be fine
I I think that would be that would be
more than fine actually I think the the
really important thing that maybe some
people might overlook here is remember
yeah destiny - did seem a little bit
unfinished but remember it was supposed
to come out when the when rise fire did
rise of iron was never supposed to exist
this time it seems that they've they've
given themselves that extra year of
development time intentionally you know
it's not it's not the way this time
around they're planning on taking it and
I I have every confidence that
especially after the the responsive
destiny one and especially this you need
to if they need to delay it they will
but and you know I trust them to make
all that all that those judgment calls
but I also think that especially with
Christopher Barrett and being in the
position he is with the live team and
being able to lead it as successfully
yes he has been now I think they could
recover a lot better from that than a
year worth of drought with the rise of
iron
anyway if if if what you were going for
is instead of the savathun DLC we get a
fourth annual past thing like so we get
these three and then they release
another annual pass and they're like
here's four content drops and that'll
hold this over to destiny two or
whatever I think that's perfect or just
sorry excuse me just need three that
that'll work just as well we just need
content I don't I don't think I think
destiny would take a harder hit from a
Content drought then then anything yeah
at this point yeah because my before and
cognate is probably gonna correct me
like the whole for thing in your past
isn't something I'd even said before
honestly mine is like if they flat-out
took a break with all this stuff duking
it out and everything and then just came
back full swinging I was like that's
kind of my wonders if they'd literally
took the time to just go full on on d3
but I mean as you're saying it's like
the time off as well it's just my debate
of like the balance between the two but
as you've also mentioned they have had a
pretty good cadence with the live team
which has helped them maintain stability
and as you said if you fall off the map
incognito set it to falling completely
off the map with all the stuff you worry
about mindshare but if you come back
completely guns blazing on d3 if they do
it right either way what they do before
they have no man I hope d3 is amazing oh
dude I I have every confidence it will
be
you know but Bungie is in their swing
right now they've got it mmm I know I'm
ready I'm ready
does that sit in coach so well I will
say before you do that though shout out
the hope 160 million dollars as Hogue
said it is a hell of a commitment to
your own property no absolutely and I
assume that's why they're doing things
like the ever verse bundles next next
year and you know it might seem like Oh
every verse bundles won't cover that but
keep in mind Activision made what two
billion dollars I'm microtransactions so
we've already made the edit to the ever
verse now that's the big little
controversy right now right with the
prismatic facet right going away so
they've already shown that look we don't
monetize you don't say any and guys I'm
not even that great like I'm not upset
I'm not mad about it I'm you know I
bought I bought both the things for
crimson days I'll continue to do it but
now that they're now that I know my
money's going to Bungie and not
Activision I will absolutely support a
business that I I love and I want to
succeed and I won't courage of other
people to do the same
yeah I mean listen this is this is
interesting time period you know and I
mean I mean I shed a little bit on both
of your sides as far as what you think
you know as far as I'm wit scale in the
sense that in my opinion they cannot
afford to go away you know saying it
can't because the part where I disagree
with you scatter I think you're
seriously under estimating division I
think the difference with division is
that massive has set there and learned
from every mistake at least initially
based on what's being presented we'll
get into you know from the Division one
and that player base is strong and
regardless of how we feel about as
destiny fans about that game you know
boots on the ground Call of Duty and
rainbow succeeds type games they still
have a place you know I'm saying though
those things are still top sellers and
now they're taking from the destiny
playbook with raids with all this stuff
clans I mean and they're very extensive
improvements they're looking to play
yeah here you know saying so I don't
anticipate unless they completely
botched the launch it's completely
non-functional and you know we've got
all type of craziness running around
I expect a hit now just like you said
though every Luther shooters gonna get a
hit no one's nothing consistent in this
type of climate however you know I'm
saying like get it right in my opinion
and then anthem is still is them right
they still have a chance to improve
regardless to this rough start and the
sales we all agree that all three of us
love that game we love lying around
again we feel it feels good it does
something unique that the other two do
not do right on some level so if they
improve and we know cataclysms army
right
what if cataclysms are awesome like what
I've got it was really cool and then it
gets a little basement again this is all
in conjunction with what's going on with
destiny now with this ease of the
drifter seasonal opulence sounds good I
think this is good to get people's
piqued interest but in my opinion you
know the season pass for me I'm not
saying it's terrible I just feel that
come you know fall of this year they
need something big we need to really get
people excited they need another
Forsaken they need some day it I think
it would be crazy not to be in the mind
share all of a base because again if the
vision the vision same the content if
anthem continually improves throughout
the year and there's no destiny that
that gets a little right now I do I do
agree with E in this sense though like
you don't obviously don't want things
rushed right you don't want them just to
push out something just to make me meet
some specific date so to speak when it's
ready it's ready you know I'm saying so
that's the cool part of being free from
Activision you know but at the same time
I think something does have to drop this
year maybe if it doesn't drop September
4 drops October they need a little bit
more time you know I'm saying whatever
November they need to stay away cuz at
the end if they call it Duty it's still
there yeah it will play with Call of
Duty that's it so you want to give that
a chance to breathe so still something
end of the year and then we'll see what
happens now I will say this if they do
what you guys say and they continue the
Annual Pass
you know um drip-feed contest so to
speak I would be upset I wouldn't be
like ok you know all this is you know
completely bad or whatever whatever I
wouldn't be upset if they did that you
know she just damn well d3
has to be
what it needs to be here you know say
that that's all I'm saying and for me
it's little cross progression cross play
the next generation consoles will be out
in 2020 and um yeah you know so we shall
see I mean me personally I think they
need something strong to end the year
off before you know um yes degree but
it'll be interesting to see how they
handle it man this is exciting this is
exciting time to see you know three
looter shooters out here you know and I
don't want to disrespect warfarin
warframes do is another one right like
it's it's so many things right now yeah
I think the important thing that we can
learn from anthem though is that if if
the division doesn't weigh into this
they're launched perfectly I I think
people are done with triple-a titles to
launching at not 5% yeah and that's the
thing like I you know you mentioned
cataclysms and stuff and anthem and I
I'm really excited for it in all DLCs
free and stuff but I think especially
after this rocky rocky start there's
only so much of that player base they're
getting back and I think if if division
doesn't hit it perfectly and it doesn't
have that end game that everyone wants
that it's currently already in full
force and destiny I don't think they'll
maintain their player base which I
admittedly admittedly I you know we we
didn't really discuss any of this but
I'm not a huge division fan I I didn't
play actually I've never played
deficient good drop the bomb because I
played it but I hate it division like I
am a division hater like it's so funny
to meet it the kind of champion in it a
little bit because I didn't like the
first one but what I will say just
interrupt you real quick is is that they
have addressed every issue in my opinion
that was fundamentally wrong with the
game hmm does that so I'm sitting there
and I'm like okay you know let's see you
know and again the end game to me listen
what I realized I'll say this last day
and I'll give it back to you at the end
of the day let's just keep it all the
way 100 when it comes to gun play game
mechanics raids no one's touching
destiny when Destiny's on its it it's
the best
that's just my pimp call me fanboy Curie
but that's just
I feel you don't say yeah again the vibe
up getting is like they're literally
trying to copy the playbook over their
bathroom they like okay they're trying
to do it in their own little way you
know kind of thing yeah interesting to
see but I know what you're saying about
it I'll give it back in reference to
your experience with division
yeah a well I mean that's the thing is
like I I'm a very much an outsider
looking in I going into it I I don't
like third person usually and I'm not
really a huge Ubisoft fan
so the original Division III didn't
touch and then I was I was it was one of
those games I was like oh I'll pick it
up six months after launch or whatever
and then it got destroyed and I was like
okay well that turned out exactly like I
thought it was gonna turn out and now
here we are again version two you know I
I will admit I've heard a lot of better
better stuff but nothing in Division has
sounded as promising as anthem and I
mean anthem got slaughtered and I mean
you how do you how do you argue with all
free DLC I'm that that's the thing that
kills me about anthem is like I the game
mechanics are there the DLC is there the
the dev response is there I just don't
understand why it didn't land because
it's very much a 90 percent game you
know there's obviously issues with the
glaring issues but it's it's like a 90
out of 100 percent game and if it didn't
weigh in the stick the landing like I
thought it was I just a man the division
better have a freaking magic rabbit and
it's hack or it's it's not gonna land
very hard or it's not gonna land very
softly it's gonna increase Carol we will
revisit this well actually I invite you
back let's do it
no no no I'm happy - I'm happy that's
like it I'm actually really interesting
this because like I said I haven't been
keeping up with this at all well you
know what a little bit of stuff in and
I've read like the basic stuff that all
this new stuff I haven't seen and I you
know I'm not I'm not again or you know
I'll admit I was wrong if I am I and I
gladly and I'll pick up the game they'll
play and I'll have a hell of fun time
but right now I just you know we'll see
where it goes we'll see where he goes I
see this except for descries transition
we may as well just talk about it you're
in the middle of it anyway I said a bit
of it man it look again shout-out to PD
and a chat you know say he's I he's he's
trying to take credit for converting me
into this big division family you know
at the end of day they drop some content
and you know they talk about the year
one pass which I have up on the screen
they're talking about obviously you know
I listen to the division stream and oh
[ __ ] first Varga boys you gotta work on
your stream really it's so technical but
it's not that's one thing Bungie just
does so well is no deej there is no cool
smoking jacket you know they just yeah
very technical and it got to work on
making it a little bit more fan friendly
but listen to it it was really cool in a
sense that you know the way they
described it you see on the Left we got
these three episodes and the vibe is
this scare like what they're doing is
okay you've got DC's been taken over it
you've got these three major factions I
can't quote me on the names right now
but all I even remember those I don't
remember their name they have different
place down what is like the jackals or
something like that and the other one is
two other ones right they're all vying
for control of Washington DC so as you
play the story right and then issue
qur'anic progress further and then you
get towards the end game content you
know I'm saying what they're saying is
not only do you have strongholds they're
talking about obviously we talked about
raid we talked about dedicated pvp we
talked about dark zone which is that PvE
versus PvP kind of mix kind of deal and
then what they mention of the year one
past is they're now talking about three
story narrative based content drops that
are free that continue the story post
launch right this is something that they
set on stream that they have said it
look you know narrative Lee wise we got
killed for that right we didn't really
address things and then the other thing
that they mentioned which is really cool
to me is the specialization so pretty
much what happens is think of it like a
you know when you start off and then you
get to max level then you can kind of
pick your subclass so to speak
specialize I believe one it's kinda like
a demolition garden is you know there's
another one with the omelet this
crossbow thing and then there's a whole
certain tree set and mid maxing that you
can do for for that clever each class
for each specialization now with the
year one pass what they're talking about
is post release
then they're unleashing another three
more specialization so again in
definitely terms it's the equivalent of
three more subclasses that he's at the
at the at the end so you got that you
got the classified assignments which
will again be story content and then for
the first time and shout out the Attic I
know he's in here she's a big raid guy
right one of our biggest critiques with
the division was that the in-game
content yeah let's call it what it is
incursion to try a spade a spade yeah it
was direct first one was actually the
worst I heard they did improving anger
for the first one was yeah if you want
me to describe it quickly for you scare
oh basically put an APC in an
underground large concrete room somehow
you have to try and kill this thing
enemies coming at you yeah it was and
it's just like firing missiles in a room
I'm like outside of all the physics
behind the reasons you would die it
wasn't fun
feedback the heart you know and now what
they're doing is again according to the
devs you know full dedicated raids a
shout to my boy Eric screaming I've had
him on our little podcast Eric's gaming
I had one I'll pee before and um he
actually has a great video where he sat
down with them and he's a big raid guy
so he's like okay you know is this gonna
be bullet sponge you know or are we
gonna have mechanics and the devs are
very clear they're like no this is gonna
be mechanic based you know I mean eight
players again we have to see it but it
sounds exciting we have to see how its
implemented but it sounds you know
pretty cool so you know we got that
content you know going on and then like
I said the bounties project that they
talked about the clan system you know
there's some really cool features very
rich very even two level of destiny as
far as you know the whole ranking of
your clan members their dedicated chat
rooms per you don't saying so they are
coming they are coming as we know the
the the open beta is now what's for free
so scarole you could try it I'll give it
a shot for sure for sure hey like I said
at the end of the day you know I was
impressed
just with the level of content you know
I didn't think that they would have this
amount of content
they also also have dedicated pvp so for
people who don't like the dark zone you
know they have that and then the last
thing about dark zone which is something
that kind of stayed away from and you
know I've kind of expressed on the show
before that my main reason for staying
away from it was because you know if you
were a hardcore player that really had
all these high-level gear sets and all
these perks that if you jumped into that
game mode you would get rekt and now
with the three dark zones and basically
they have one roaming occupied doctrine
which will retain that level of you know
high-level guys will be the dominant
factor but the rotating one the other
two will be normalized so people like us
who are casual division players are come
in and you it's normalized stats almost
think think of it as a put like iron
banner versus standard crucible
resurrect you know say so to speak so
again they did just seem to be very
receptive to the feedback that a lot of
the Division one players had a lot of
people who were kind of on the fence
with it and it's gonna be interesting is
gonna be interesting so I thought it was
cool you know it's out right now for
those like I said wanna give it a shot
see what it's about but they are
definitely dedicated to pulse
post-launch content as well as um
continuing on throughout the year and
they did save raids so this is raid
number one I believe it's um it's the
Denver it's like beyond dark or hours or
something to that effect
mmm Airport yeah and you know we got to
see we got to see what they do and I was
gonna give it to you guys on that if you
guys get a chance catch that uh that
trailer and they also doing strongholds
which also surprised me which is um
basically the last thing I'll say on
this is that again once you end the
campaign and gear yourself up you're
getting ready for the endgame content
you know this new faction appears it's
called the black tusk they now take over
the map so think of it like the taken
war so to speak and now they're in all
the missions you know I'm saying so um
that's that new faction now they
apparently one of the stronghold
missions is going to be infiltrating
that factions base so to speak so um
yeah man it's it's pretty cool I think
it's I think they're coming you know
it's gonna be interesting to see if they
can keep it up and II did you get a
chance to watch the
at least I don't know if you've been
busy if I were with one for the the
one-year one Content trailer I did watch
it it was kind of a brief piece where
mm-hmm
so I don't kind of remember every single
piece of it but yeah I definitely got a
got to watch a little bit they talked
about episode 1 so it's kind of like
picture annual past part one that's the
DC outskirts where you kind of go more
into the suburban areas episode 2 of
course like the Pentagon is like the
structure of course for anything related
DC so the fact that we actually kind of
get to go in there seems cool and then
the 3 seems more open the
specializations it looks like can't
really tell from the picture this one
looks like kind of a heavy machine-gun
here I can't tell the other two but it
does seem like they do have a lot that
went more in depth on the
specializations and things like that and
again it seems like there's a lot of
depths of a game and I haven't really
argued that Minds literally and probably
for anybody is do you enjoy the feel of
the game if you enjoy the
boots-on-the-ground if you enjoy the
cover shooter if you enjoy the military
feel the min maxing RPG if you want an
RPG like military shooter this is your
game like this literally has your name
plastered all over it because this is
going to give you the depth a whole lot
of like different factions defeat shoot
different mechanics like getting
advanced in the war fight type stuff
when you fight the black tusk right it
has a lot of stuff to offer offer their
Annual Pass is basically also free like
anthem so scare oh they're kind of got a
same model Bungie is the only one who's
actually charging which is the odd one
out shout out when you get stuff like
season The Drifter I'll pay for it so I
mean they're free content as well now
they have their randoms like okay so
everybody gives anthem crap because of
the release launch window and stuff like
that if you want to see what it's like
when you preorder different versions of
the division that's worse
why don't say that it's no it's not the
release window it's like well some get
you early access some get you that when
you get so say so this is PvE content
but there's a PvP element to it say
somebody gets three days early access to
something in destiny that would kind of
break a lot of things this gives three
days early acts
and then this is seven-day early access
for the pre-order and if you buy this
pass you get early access to new stuff
yeah just repaying the extra money so
those are some of the pieces to this
that is like kind of gonna I mean
everybody's making their money in
different ways but that early access
piece just kind of rubs me weird I wish
that I would agree they talk about the
three specializations being able to be
unlocked for early access guys you know
yeah that is a little is it it's like
they've given up like yeah if you buy
destiny early you'll get you know those
three subclasses but it would be like I
mean it would be like you know the last
it would be scores of the past it
releases a week early if you paid for
the pass it wasn't a oh actually they
just talk about the specialization for
my understanding from our saying oh
there's a seven-day early access to year
one to step asoto so just like okay but
there's like the pre-order for at least
like some of them for the actual
episodes themselves you get like three
days early access for pre-ordering like
a version of the game mm-hmm
I mean those are just weird little
tidbits and stuff like that I mean the
game has a lot to offer and if they
don't pull the Destiny to saying hey
let's figure out everything we learned
throw it on a bookshelf and try
something new like that would if they
take the development learn but also it's
like when you jump in you play the game
and some of the things about it are way
too they took like a UI mm-hmm I will
say Destiny's UI beats both of them
hands down oh yeah divisions and anthems
both need some help because to this time
there's so much clicking and like
double-clicking and like going through
six menus for things and then even like
I forget who said it you're looking at
your skill trees and you're looking at
the menu and you're like I don't even
know which one I have selected because
the picture doesn't change Wow
so there's certain pieces when it comes
to UI elements and stuff like that but
when it comes to a cover based system
it's one of the best ones I've ever
played the feel of it shooting the guns
the actual psychological piece about the
armored enemies feels better because
they actually have armor that breaks and
then they die really fast as opposed to
bullets Bungie crazy things like an
anthem when you're shooting an ER six or
in destiny when you're shooting a giant
ogre it makes sense that you probably
gonna have to shoot him a few more times
one of the shooting a guy in a bandana
he should
and that's one of those things they've
actually like I mean they're gonna have
some harder enemies
yes it's an RPG but I like the armor for
the psychological nature of like I have
to shoot this guy's armor like 20 times
on his hip and then when it finally
breaks if I shoot the hip then I can
take him down quickly that was one of
those things like for me that was like
okay that at least makes sense on my
head more they did pretty with the bat
that's you you kid killer I mean like
yeah Scarah if you got time this weekend
I mean because it is the down week
before unless you're trying to grind
something else out which is nice they
moved the pins out for ya that's need to
as well um play it it's free I would
know it's wrong I'll give it a couple
hours at least yeah I was like I'd
actually kind of be curious to get your
thoughts like hit us up in our little uh
Twitter deep group afterwards a letter
no I'm serious because if you didn't
play d1 and you're kind of step in and
I'm honestly curious what you think of
this yeah I'll check it out I'll see
what happens much all I got like I said
for those guys out there just give it a
shot if you want to see what it's about
it's out there out here in these streets
and that's all I got man but uh what
else we got four and before we wrap up
as I know we got us some patch notes and
stuff going on with uh what anthem right
yeah we've had a couple different
patches they've worked on there's two
different sets this is one of the hot
fixes that went out yesterday so shout
out to first off all the guys working on
this team guys gals everybody put in
time into anthem and this is where I
have my faith in Bioware and Ubisoft to
support other games as well where the
like they've taken Division one from a
very very very rocky launch and like
stuck with it they have stuck with their
games more than anybody else I've seen
yeah Ubisoft man and they're like
eyewear wants to from what I can see
from in Irving Michael Campbell all
those guys out there Casey Hudson any of
those names that I've seen on Twitter
the support and the love for this game
it's real the passion you can watch it
in every stream and the only difference
is if EA is gonna give the money to do
it so that's the one we have to watch
and they want to if they get the money
to continue to maintain it and as you
said this is kind of one of the things
where you're like okay so we get the you
know we get to see what this next three
months looks like some people are ring
and scare o for you this may like work a
little better because you love the grind
for like
I want that next legendary you may get a
legendary like you know jump out of your
chair and then jump back and be like
sweet and you're good but for some as
you get like you only get one one
stronghold in April the Cataclysm does
come in May the garage and the rocky
launch for some this has been
questionable but we're a week from the
original launch two weeks from the early
access so depends on how you want to
look at it like just the way the loot
has been dropping and we've got changes
for this is probably one of the biggest
things and this is one thing destiny has
got to do mm-hmm
items no longer have inscriptions on
them they're not appropriate for that
specific item I cannot tell you how many
times I get a sniper with hipfire grip I
want to throw my finger and I cannot
stand that I should not a you know an
auto rifle that gives Plus shotgun ammo
like that and that's the type of stuff
those hams happening in anthem all right
you're a you know a ability gear for my
interceptor and it's gonna help
something that doesn't even make sense
so like there are certain things that
they went and they were like okay quick
run-through fix the loot so things are
actually correct now they also helped
with the crafting materials and there's
a couple more things that they have
coming and there's some other fixes in
here I don't know where the other patch
notes are so I'm not entirely sure
what's that but the fact that they
changed like the way the loot system is
dropping due to like feedback from the
community in literally like a week
mm-hmm very quick is like that's damn
fast and I just kinda want to get your
thoughts on for one your thoughts on
anthem so so far scare Oh since it
sounds like you have been playing it
suit your thoughts on where it's been
and how you do you think the Annual Pass
is gonna be not the annual pass but the
at least act one content how do you feel
about that yeah so you know obviously I
don't want to be I don't want to have
like the 40 minute conversation that
everyone's been having about this you
know I pretty much everything's been
said real quickly I I am on the side
that's enjoying it that being said even
for a granny player like myself some of
these things arguing while they were
done it for instance the challenge of
Valor after you complete campaign you
have to do a hundred public events
they'll know I'm not doing that stop it
just get help
you know like I'm not doing that I very
much recognize the complaints with
pretty much every encounter of the game
is one of like five certain encounters
you have the things we gotta pick stuff
up or stand on a certain object or
whatever I get it like I said I'm not
naturally a fan of third-person things
either so that doesn't help but in terms
of the loot system in the game I in the
combat system
I've actually been very much enjoying it
it's just you know I I see the same
problems everyone else does I just I
think it's got a little bit more
sticking power with me I think it's one
of those games I'm not gonna play every
single day like destiny but it'll keep
me coming back on a weekly basis you
know log in for a couple hours every
Sunday or something yeah the challenge
this week or whatever and the fact I
really love things like the therapy
Giants challenge last week where you had
five days to get this challenge done if
you didn't do it tough luck you don't
get the final I think that's so cool I
love that sort of stuff and then in
terms of Act one I think M Tash really
put it best man I was really excited for
it but it's so far out and it's it's one
of those things like destiny vanilla
lasted by itself a long time because it
had the raid because I had all these
things you needed to grind for but you
know strongholds aren't cutting it
they're just not there they're alright
but I think at the end of the day I
personally would rather just go run
around free play then do a stronghold
especially with random people because
you're gonna be there for hours in terms
of you know that's the game overall I
give it about a seven point five out of
ten yeah you know that's a very
arbitrary ranking system obviously but I
think that that's a good maybe an 8
depending on the day that's that's
specifically kind of like the end game
I've spent a lot of time in there I'm
enjoying it I'm gonna keep playing it
but the thing that's really standing out
from this game is the dev team this is
incredible the fact that they've been
able to turn around this quickly every
time for all these fixes and stuff and
that they're so willing to say that they
got something wrong and that they'll fix
it because we like it better a certain
way and you know I I think
once I start getting because I only have
one legendary maybe a couple I don't
remember as once I started getting into
the more crazy drops I think I'll start
gettin to the part where I really enjoy
it but it's when you know III don't
understand the hate for it but I get
that
III don't understand for the hate for
the game where it is right now but I
understand people being not very happy
about new content being so far out yeah
yeah yeah
I mean um yeah I think kind of pretty
much on the same page I mean it's like I
said they D the potential is dead I mean
there's still a fun factor there there's
still a lot of a great class energy you
know I mean that I like the uniqueness
of each of each class and stuff like
that I was with you you know when I
heard about stuff with the tunes and
stuff that kind of rubbed me the wrong
way in reference to that but um and yeah
the strongholds you know one of them we
already had from the um you know that
the prior demo one is a remixed
literally of the end of the cave
you know they so the struggles are
definitely not something I'm really
interested in you know for me it's it's
all about Cataclysm what is that and
it's a little disappointing that it's so
far out you know it's like I'm like I
didn't think we'd have to wait till May
you know cool thing about hit them for
me it's kind of what you said scout
which is I actually have fun just going
into free before hey doing what I want
to do you know they got a big but um you
know listen I mean this thing it's a
good compliment game go to like a tuck a
destiny so to speak like if you want to
get in there you want to get in a few
hours and stuff like that and I will say
this I do agree with you guys though
like the debt this dev team has been
amazing as far as like transparency as
far as quickly as far as speed you know
really being able to implement this
stuff as far as a loop the mass works
and all that kind of stuff that's great
that's the kind of stuff you want to see
Bungie really adopt you not I mean
because it's real it really note not
much of a delay it gets back in I'm not
saying is I just want them to stick with
stick with it man keep putting this
stuff out you know and um hopefully if
they can just move that schedule up
because again may is a long time you
know
you know once the rest of the community
catches up and you know they tunes and
they beat the the main you know the
campaign then you know I just don't want
it to be that low period where it's just
like okay what else do I do
am I gonna do Grandmaster you know kind
of deal and then that's it and then kind
of hightail it out because that's these
contents here or divisions contents here
or what have you so you know that that's
where I'm at when it still a lot a game
you know I'm gonna still give it a shot
you know as much as I possibly can I
just want them to support it that's all
I just keep get printed bringing out
content shout-out to somebody in the
community I've got to confirm it
somewhere but speculation here is shut
up to PC gamer as of literally right now
next week sir Forsaken exotics log me to
the say that I knew that yes nice win
where was that posted I just missed it
yeah it was I believe PC gate was
someone sent that to me
we forgot to mention it during the
dessert segment yes yes yeah that for
finally long window so like on that one
seriously like it should have started in
like black armory personally it's been
three months yet the other stuff get
going you don't have to wait another six
I mean yeah if you get a new release the
old stuff so you should start coming
like yeah take three months if you can
earn them if you don't time to catch up
like that just seems reasonable at least
have it in his ridiculous randomness
that's whether I mean it may not be
there for like six weeks but give it the
option video I need you to wake me up
out of sleep
I'm taking my mammoth of a computer if
you look up the dark Bass Pro 900 for a
case you know it's not small and that's
going with me to Kansas on the second
weekend when the quest starts so believe
me I'm doing it this I just if my
internet doesn't die I literally didn't
do my sir video today because the
internet was had been down all day and
at this point it's useless so I won't do
it today but I do have to log in and
check and see what he's got but tell me
geobags is available Oh completely
unlucky on warlock forsaken exotics and
it's just like man I want to know what
that feels like I want to know what
you know figs protocol feels like like I
don't none of these things to tail Fox
like nothing like I need subdued sir so
yeah that'll be cool that's good
breaking news yeah here's the sir video
for the week the colony peacekeepers
knucklehead radar and claws of ahankara
I'll go get clowny cuz I don't have it
on PC no mmm
so that I think pretty much wraps it up
but yeah it's like I mean I'm kind with
you guys on anthem it's something that
is honestly got a lot of potential and
I'm kind of like with you I love just I
literally love like wonder free play
just roaming
that's the part that feels amazing and
that's the part they need to dive deeper
into and give it more
I like the abilities that kind of like
the fun I love my interceptor which I'm
sorry if I may know anybody on Twitch or
up from motion sickness but I love what
my interceptor is able to do it's
probably just the worst one to play on
stream either way it's kind of um it has
a really good foundation and it's one of
those things I hate saying because
that's what we said about destiny we're
like this is the game like we love and
we're passionate for being it has a the
the framework is there we just want more
we need more stuff to do and that's just
those points where I think yeh pushed it
too fast so yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
fly through one more thing because I
know this has been an insane day is uh
we're gonna just scroll through season
The Drifter you got the Vidocq so you
guys can go out there and read that
gambit prime we discussed we discussed
Reaper invader collector in century
those here for I don't want to make sure
we don't miss anything
reckoning PvE activity lore pinnacle PvE
crazy camp this is your little Bank
thing I think yeah so you got new
weapons and armor this has got to be a
pulse rifle and I think I'd like it the
most mm-hmm people were pointing out
that those gauntlets don't appear to
match the armor set so they're thinking
they're new exotic arm pieces there's
one year yeah uh-huh yeah that is one in
the bottom left that especially looks
really exotic mmm-hmm yeah that's one
piece like we don't have any word on I
mean they they gave too much away I
think in black armor that here's your
exotics and they all had their yes you
had to give them
yeah I've got to assume there's some
exotics and things that are in this yes
hopefully so that will be there the
power surge of any as we talked about
iron banner will be coming back
they did we didn't talk about the iron
banner burden and we didn't talk about
the burden of got about oh you can drop
your power level basically up to a
hundred points to give yourself a
disadvantage in iron banner but you get
kind of like trove triumphs and things
for it oh wow really that's awesome yeah
Ursa and yeah and you can also boost it
up mmm that's crazy
I can't wait to mess with that playing
with the power level mechanic in my
mm-hmm that's weird
please let iron banner have at least a
little more variety than just always
control oh it's right there say exotic
weapons and armor by the way so we are
nice annual past owners can add more of
the best cut weapons so their collection
and the pinnacle chase Oh didn't even
talk about the pinnacles oh yeah sorry
I'm at 10:48 for my time but yeah these
guys are definitely getting some late
late East Coast hours so appreciate them
sticking with it and those if you guys
still in stream as well so which one do
you guys want to hit first gambit PvE or
PvP do you save the best for last to go
with it first do you pick let's say you
got it first
alright let's do one cuz that stuff
that's gonna be mental it's gonna be
real nutty okay 21% delirium kills
increase this weapons damage until it is
stowed or you Oded plus it has a new
perk called overflow I think yep where
it's essentially just like ambitious
assassin but on steroids mmm it's gonna
be incredible yeah sounds beast yeah I'm
not sure if the other two can live up so
Cognito you can take the crucible one
since here the crucible guy here a
recluse yeah lightweight void sub Feist
look I like device if I say always got
those cool I do like their models
they're kind of jagged yeah mess so let
master of arms perk man kills with any
weapons and cruel this weapons damage
for a short time and they commented
about how they know some machines are
not in a good place and yeah by so they
basically giving you this massive
massive arm perks and you can just pull
this bad boy out put it on whatever
Weber you kill you get more damage for a
short time so you know this is gonna be
interesting to see if it can actually
counter shotguns and inside officer
stuff so yeah it was gonna be to get
that deck that quest going man
competitive gonna be sweating again yeah
somebody's gonna have to grind it out
and see if it's worth it the first the
first review that comes out for this gun
it's gonna have like a million views I'm
yeah well I have a team ready oh there
we go shoutouts Cairo follow this man
yes to the info yeah last but not least
the oxygen sr3 so Dragonflight deals
more damage based on the number of
precision hits made beforehand mm-hmm so
picture giant ogre pump them up and then
you may as well just wipe everything
that's it near him is what it sounds
like at least but it's a scout rifle so
I'm not sure kind of how I'm feeling
about those still we'll have to see how
this one feels but I'm hoping it's not
another loaded question where it sounds
great in theory but in practice it's not
that great yeah I mean a loaded question
how that was worth like I know how to
use it just why do I never use a little
question because I close right like why
you know that's that's that's my thing I
knew it you know I've got some
functionality for it
I trust me I was the same when I
couldn't get it's actually knocked out
um but again I'm using Luna faction I
have a specific build for it and yeah
like it could be deadly mark we have
users yo yeah could you get aqua quick
there we go no we crazy late and we
going over but I it wouldn't be right if
I didn't bring skim through that the
sandbox thing real quick if you don't
mind cuz they go for it where were we
looking I know I'm gonna put scour to
sleep but I'm fine bro
you know I sweet us
I don't wanna call myself kid because
I'm not a kid but I see up all my it's
whatever man 35 years old area oh well
there you go you know us gamers man
we're crazy for life yeah man they've
made some comments about the sandbox
changes upcoming some actually just for
season adrift it'll let me switch over
to the table yeah nice wallpaper by the
way the thorn that is now on on my work
computer on my home computers everything
yeah shut up so the artists up there so
quick 12 12 1 through when we get there
I'll let you see I'm just trying to make
sure we don't miss anything so we got
everything about seasons of drifter Rita
look at it calendar we know that stuff
the gameplay Karen calendar prime
accessibility they break down a little
deeper on the rolls and there are boy
that's inquiry colorblind so incredible
shout out to them for that that's really
cool
I'm sure I'm gonna butcher this the
Deuter deuteron Opia protanopia and
tried to nokia so hitting the colorblind
still making them distinct which is it's
interesting to see this from my
perspective to see what they actually
would be looking at for the differences
though this one looks the hardest they
do oh yeah I agree
for sure cuz that like these two I'm not
as close as they can get these finally
like the pink the purple yeah that one
about so yeah uh yeah we've got the
three peaks so you got Scouty SMG LMG
that one looks looks so good oh one
thing I really love about it is you get
if you see the surra Signia they've
started to like scratch him off yeah
yeah that's really cool so like the
drifters like rebranded it with again
yeah that's really cool nice and this
they said is the first rapid fire
machine gun so bullet hose picture I
can't remember the like one from d1 but
it's your first little faster firing for
sure just pumping out like probably 99
in the mag so
uh sandbox here we go okay so go for it
yeah they do pretty much this was
another surprise to me they pretty much
you know they talked about the weapons
obviously after the announce of the
pinnacle they pretty much talk about
exotic power weapons they're talking
about you know as far as that being a
go-to and they had a thought process
they basically said you know exotics
will always have you know their unique
properties and stuff like that you know
but they're basically saying that
exotics should you know should be an
expression but it shouldn't be just the
only option and that a well rolled
legendary power weapons should be able
to complete and compete in raw damage
with an exotic power weapon so they go
on to get into um grenade launchers PvE
damage increased by 25%
we got reserve ammo increased on most
grenade launches in most cases grenade
launchers getting three rounds and
reserves but this amount may vary based
on the perks you have failed prep etc
and then magazine perks and mods no
longer affect ammo reserves that was
interesting to me so I said okay and
then um you know they continue to go on
as far as the um rocket launches and
this one is big in my opinion on PvE
damage increased by sixty to sixty-five
percent so that's the legendary PvE
rocket launchers exotic rocket launchers
will have their damage tuned separately
now this is the big one and cluster bomb
we all know if that rocket launcher
don't have clustered ball B Chardon it
so to see the damage room yeah damage
reduced by 80 but then they explain
their gonna explain himself and they
said the lost damage that was moved to
the rocket launchers main projectile
it's noted above what the damage
increased that's that sixty to
sixty-five percent you know I'm saying
that's the kind of compensating so they
don't want cuz they're going to be
completely ridiculous so um yeah they
said pretty much said the same process
that rocket launches with we're too
dependent on cluster bombs like full
auto on shotguns cluster bombs with
nearly double the damage output of any
given rocket the result was all that I
want to target at all you can couldn't
get the cluster bomb impact in detonate
so you pretty much say rocket launchers
fell by the wayside pretty harshly it's
very true but moving most of the damage
of cluster bombs into the rocket itself
rocket launchers will now be more
reliable and more effective all the way
around especially against alien aerial
targets that cluster bombs will
never damage so I just wanted to bring
this to you guys like what do you feel
about the exotic power slot thought
process with these changes I'll just use
Rat King the one phase driven and said
will be fun gonna say that's the big one
is the cluster bomb a ribbon strat
that's funny yeah well I mean yeah I'm
sure you do they might do enough damage
anyways right cuz they increased it by
65 percent cluster bomb still do 20
percent more damage because there was
only reduced by a you right so it we
five manned it with cluster bombs the
other day I'm sure with six six full
power Rockets even after this you'll
you'll still be able to one phase I'm I
don't think it's that big of a deal yeah
well that'll be a that'll be a very
early test when all this comes out yeah
yeah for sure for sure but I mean
grenade launchers PvE damage for sure I
like that because I mean I'll still I
pulled out prospector the other day
because I was going like heavyweight
arcsin John and I'd fall just to run
something different it still feels like
I don't want them nerfing machine guns
because they feel powerful I mean they
feel Opie honestly but if they could
bring other power weapons up to that
that would be better so I'm kind of like
in this for sure for PvE because the
single-shot for a rocket launch for
hitting like an absolute truck makes
sense because especially as they said if
it's in the air the cluster bombs don't
even make sense and you're not gonna
want to run it anyway so there's really
no benefit so this is good
and the grenade launchers getting above
by 25% they basically said grenade
launchers with the ammo perks and mods
there were different ones that had
different metal like reserves and things
like that so I think they're kind of
normalizing that a little better which
will be good and then if you have
reserves you'll still have a bit more I
mean I ran in Prospect right I had 19
grenades which is a lot so I was able to
still kill the warden of nothing guy at
the end pretty much in about six seconds
it's it's really weird because the
mountain top I believe is the only watch
Andheri weapon that a full six-man team
can use in one phase every raid boss in
the game so this is just gonna make it
even better Wow yeah I think I think it
was tier 1 ended up one phasing
insurrection with which means yeah
mountaintop can one face
every boss which is here edible that's
before this change mind you so you know
interesting to see those tests come up
yep yep just what I do you want to throw
that in E because you know I'm the stand
backs guy I get excited with stupid
little changes like this like I get all
excited ready to test things out was the
comes out and then we got one more piece
and shout out to hope you again this is
kind of bringing it back to this the
ever seasonal update is going to be
changing things up because prismatic
matrix is going away so I just wanted
you guys quick thoughts on this of them
taking the prismatic matrix away making
them more basically based on silver
they're direct purchases but again I
don't know how it's gonna rotate through
like what do you guys think about this
real quick
so for me I I never use prismatic facets
and I already get everything but that's
because I play too much of this game up
to this guy with 1800 hours and that's
not talking for that my mom might be
watching this dude she doesn't maybe
known that you know it's public
information no but really like I you
know I don't really use them that often
that being said it is a it's a slippery
slope but like I said a while ago I have
no problem supporting bungee and I
actually encourage myself to and my
friends too as well so that being said I
I want to see where this goes
this is one of those things I can't pass
judgement until I see what type of
cosmetics they they offer and if you
know what everything's looking like so
I'm really gonna have to wait to see
what it looks like in game before I pass
judgment yeah listen I mean this you
know this is a fortunate sometimes
beginning in an outraged culture and
this is like a minor thing to me you
know at the end of the day is like you
know prismatic fact you know facets it
was something I use in the beginning I
don't like I'm kinda like scour now I
don't really have to use it you just get
all that stuff to gameplay and now
they're getting rid of it so you know
people are upset that okay now they're
introducing I guess the silver but to me
that's even better like
can't you just direct purchase what you
want you know saying like if you really
just want yeah then just go get it you
know so again I don't have a problem
when it's not gameplay breaking these
are cosmetics like dude I'm listening
I'm ironing logg pockets you know damn
well when that Lord's sigil emote came
out by the I'm buying it how y'all feel
y'all can judge me say all about doing
celebrating blue boxes it's my money I
want to get it back so again you have
the option and again as long as it's not
giving you a competitive advantage or
doing anything that's gonna break
gameplay and you know let's be real like
what we're learning about this in my
opinion is that there were some things
that Activision probably got a lot of
blame for that we're still seeing that
this is still Bungie let's be real now
we clear let's go I wish we know where
it's going now exactly they're on their
own right you know again this is
cosmetics I have no problem supporting a
studio that I love that I've invested
thousands upon thousands of hours if I
want to get my little you know the
little warm up remote they got with the
you know the forty had the chicken in
the fried that knew what did they got do
I'm gonna do it
I know I'm gonna buy it like again so
it's just it's just an option you don't
have to do it if you don't want to do it
it's cool and it's not game breaking so
I'm about supporting the studio that I
like hard are your that I mean I'm the
same thing it's like they're cosmetics
it's like if you really don't want them
don't get them if you really want to
spend some money and that's kind of
thing is as long as most of the stuff
from ever versus still earnable in the
right in grams or whatever then I'm
honestly probably gonna be fine
so the only difference is they said
there are gonna be certain cosmetics
that are gonna be in the bundles each
week and honestly if those are more
exclusive bundles then hey here's some
shaders a boon and which it's not a boob
but you guys know what I'm talking about
and then just the one thing you're
buying I'm like if you put something
better in there then maybe you'll have a
little more incentive to buy it because
honestly right now the bundles aren't
that big of a deal
and at some point I might earn them
anyway so but as you guys all said it's
going to Bungie now it's your choice to
support them
I've got however many hours between
two games of I'm just like screw it I
just want to spend 20 bucks on this just
cuz you know Bungie I'll give you a
little extra love sure because I know
what's going in their pockets and they
have a hundred and sixty million dollars
to try and figure out how to pay and
this is one of those ways that they may
do it and I'm honestly okay with that
because if you don't want to do it you
are never forced and it's not going to
change your game exactly and this last
point is that there's some times with
the prismatic facet that you miss out on
certain things that you want whether it
be an ornament like it exotic I'm a big
exotic ornament collector kind of yeah
especially when its exotic I like like I
really want specific ones so yes like I
said if they have you know my little
vigil vigilance weighing you know and
how I want it or whatever you know
exotic armor how I want it i and picking
it up and give me the option man next
I'm good with that yeah so yeah I was
like I know it's it was overhyped and
stuff like that this email it's just
kind of hilarious by the way yeah just
going through like all the things aren't
I'm ready to go and you got ornaments
for one for melfi's ins over here just a
couple basic things and you know ghosts
and chips and all that stuff is like for
me the ships usually don't do it now
that once barrel right here in the
middle there that one that wigs so cool
and they confirmed on Twitter that we're
getting an electric guitar emot-- which
is I my play electric guitar and so when
we got the acoustic I was you know kind
of it was kind of like a tease you know
I like play guitar on stream and have my
guy playing in the background like on
the on the screen and it's like it's
just not the same but now now it's the
same it's about to get real good I'm
excited yeah nice and then final piece
they did actually extend the time frame
if you guys are looking for these big
pins which is good because people
complain so much about the orangie you
have until August 31st hints they have
some kind of date for a future piece of
content post August maybe but basically
that is the all of year too but again
every last time I saw a date of like oh
this could be then I was like
and March 5th so yep you'll have plenty
of more time to do that so eventually at
some point I've actually got to start
shooting some of these eggs that I make
videos over every week ha ha ha I
literally make the videos and I'm like
eh it's right down there as opposed to
just recording it but they have some
good bug fixes coming - guitars are
supposed to get fixed for the last which
Petra's are under which thank God people
got tired of that yeah excuse me um
blind well matchmaking has actually been
an issue off and on for a while which is
good
the izanagi's burden having some issues
and just other certain things actually
getting fixed with perks working
properly and come March 5th this is
going to be going live so we've got a
downtime that's gonna be fairly short
the patch is gonna start rolling out at
9 a.m. Pacific so 11 a.m. and
maintenance should conclude it - names
you got about maybe an extra hour maybe
not just depends on how fast they
usually sometimes finish it sooner but
might have an extra hour of downtime but
it's a new season that's not too
surprising yeah shout out to any of you
guys looking to try and finish up
anything else whether it's nightfall
rank valor rank glory infamy clan
prismatic matrixes will be going away so
use them or lose them and then the only
thing that you are gonna lose is ranks
and the only progress on any quests you
are going to lose is if you need to hit
a certain rank for any of these you know
quests that you're working on the quest
themselves will stay there whether it's
you know you're working on your
breakneck or anything your status will
stay so don't worry about any of that
stuff but if it says a rank in a season
that's your only piece yeah I just want
to address something really quickly
silver spear in a bond sisters chat
brought up a good point you said I
thought they were going to find a way to
make them easier to obtain talking about
the Dreaming city cosmetics in the last
wish cosmetics and they did say that
they're revamping those drop rates as
well for those things nice yeah so yep
hold on yeah I was like I know they're
looking at that they've mentioned it for
sure I don't know if it's a it is it's
it's right but well it's at the pin
section if you go back up it's at the
very bottom of it ok right there ok
oh maybe you know maybe it's above it I
definitely ready here some titles
require the pollution of completion
vestiges which are dependent on earning
every piece of gear from various
destinations we've been collecting
feedback and currently working on a
change to drop weight to change to drop
weights associated with vanity items in
the Dreaming city and the last wish raid
additionally we are looking at Bray tech
weapon schematics thousand voices so
they're looking at basically all the
things that people cannot seem to get
and they're working on making it better
so you know Bray tech Osprey for the
rocket launcher from strange terrain
like this week may potentially become a
little quicker so yeah said Fred if you
don't finish Lunas how by Tuesday you
get to start that progress over sorry
yeah but yeah they've added some people
to some teams they got movies of the
week shout out to to Vanguard and his
like six hammer throw kill which was
hilarious and then a solo one phase
intersection prime I don't even know who
it is and he has the channel is actually
not that big but about it's about to get
bigger how did this not get movie of the
week yeah apparently vent like true
Vanguard yelled over this guy like I
need I didn't watch this but I'm gonna
go watch it and it's like a 13-minute
video like I haven't watched it yet
either but yeah it's the fact that it's
like it's there I'm like that's
impressive work so yeah probably we'll
see we'll see
yeah we'll see I gotta watch him but
that pretty much wraps it up guys so
this has been an insane week for
everybody so yeah it has been a lot of
fun to kind of get hyped up again for
something that I was actually pretty
lackluster about and honestly like I
just don't have enough time life is over
that's they got the nerve to be good
again it's crazy at the wrong moment to
just when I thought I was gonna have
time to play something else
yep um but yeah honestly shoutouts Carol
thank you for jumping in and dealing
with my insane schedule all day but it's
been a blast having you on think oh it's
been a lot of fun thank you for having
me thanks yeah thanks for rocking with
us I know we
we tend to go long but we have been
active all the way to the end I don't
mind these long conversations this is I
live in this you know you have to say
way so the good to have you appreciate
it and you know still rock with us man
and I know the schedule changed in a poy
boxes he couldn't even you know you
couldn't control what was going on so
I'm still glad we were able to do it
Matt because it was so much going on the
season a drifter so much news you know
and breakdowns and is this exciting man
this is exciting man so uh I'm high I'm
high if I'm ready you don't say no be
ready come you know next week and we're
gonna hit that contact on it man
absolutely
well scarole feel free to shout out to
everybody we got to you're in chat still
just let him know where you're at what
you've been working on and just kind of
you know anything you want to throw out
there this that this is your time so go
for it yeah absolutely well I'm scared
9:00 on YouTube and at scale 9 on
Twitter I do all my live streams and all
my videos over on YouTube I can't top
the intro that Lord gave me but yeah I
do a lot of you guys probably have seen
my exotic ranking videos they get way
too big I do five things you don't know
about destiny and all these big series
and all that sort of things so if you're
interested in learning more about the
game that we all love to spend time in
check me out over there nice great stuff
great job love the content
keep it coming man he will do well did
you guys see man carry on the legacy get
it from someone like you it's an honor
sir we uh we raised our our you know
cheetah paw and ninja hand here's my
chicken egg I guess we would need oh
let's you could wrap yours up as well
what do you got what do you got coming
this week you know last week was big
last week was big man shout to everybody
came through episode 100 man it was out
of control
100 episodes a little podcast and the
other crazy lords that I host I host a
show live but oh yeah babies 101 it's
gonna be back and
with 100 obviously we made the big
announcement we've launched our website
it's a lords of gaming dotnet so please
check it out
we've got opinion pieces we've got
walked through the e-bot this has a walk
through up there it is a solo which curl
it leaves the shattered but the ascended
challenge so oh man check us out we
definitely try to get it into the media
space so it's really cool
this week we will have another podcast
get a little podcast invasion we'll have
the four guys with quarters a great
podcast we will be on Sunday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on the island podcast YouTube
channel please check us out as you
already know I'll be YouTube also hosts
the last word podcast with my man Ibanez
you know so we talking that lunar
shooter talk you know we got a lot of a
lot of content also coming man King
right now he's doing this thing called
king of statues that's every Wednesday
at 7:00 a.m. he puts them out and pretty
much this man goes through his man cave
of like 1 by 10 scale Marvel statues and
they're amazing like like I don't know
how he has all these times they're video
check that out like I said check out the
I love podcast YouTube channel when you
can and this Sunday will be a fun show
week I talk a lot about what's going on
rumors of Borderlands being possibly
announced that packs you know halo
Infinite reboot we're gonna talk a
little little shooter stuff as well so
please check us out support if you have
a chance absolutely
and then me if you guys don't know me
I'd be surprised by now because we say
this every week but you guys know where
to find me it's youtube.com slash e
Montes if you guys aren't watching me on
Twitch and you guys are over on iron
Lords podcast it's Yvan's it's
everywhere nice thing about having a
weird name it's yours
EB ONC is if you google it you'll find
me pretty much everywhere I'm at and I
have a piece for some of you guys that
are watching I am I got honored enough
to be a guest coming up on destiny
community podcast that will be on
Thursday March 7th and being as they all
have their face cameras and stuff that's
going to be my reveal is they're gonna
be live finally Sykes they're probably
save up for that would maybe get a
haircut you know nice bowtie you know oh
oh my god I don't even know what they
would do so that one is gonna be a lot
of fun talking with those guys it's
gonna be really cool just cuz I mean
they're big people in the community and
just hats off to all of them they're all
really cool and they have their own
pieces to them so I'm just very honored
to have a chance to get in there so that
one is really cool and then outside of
that it's I have another thing coming up
potentially that I can't really say too
much about so just stay tuned
you might let's just say you might see
me in some different places and then
other than that that's pretty much all I
got so just stay tuned if you guys don't
follow me on Twitter that is probably
the best place as well outside of
YouTube I do try and post up on my
community feed but yeah GCP next week
come on guys hype it up in there next
week I want to see all you guys in there
so DCP live Thursday night pretty much
right now but yesterday I'm not gonna
let you speak past that like that's a
big deal you know say and to see your
growth and to see you to continue with
the consistency you know it's really
really cool you know and like I said ask
our if you don't know the history you
know my first Guardian con is when I
actually met II bought it in the flesh
and I'm like this kid knows his destiny
babe like we just talked to be chopped
it up and just to see his progression
and to like to be on DCP which is one of
my favorites
you know podcast in the deci space is it
gonna be like a proud dad don't sit
there I'm a feet up yeah knock it out of
the park to you congrats for sure I
honestly just getting me nervous talking
all those guys out there so it's it's
one of those things that'll be very very
much I'll just be trying not to blush
and be humble both those guys great
group of guys everybody knows you know
me so just really yeah it's like they're
they're all awesome he recognized is
really cool so definitely gonna be a
front roll camera
go get him yeah I got my Elgato key
light I've got to a green screen I'm all
set up so
yep we ready that is that is next week
so yeah Thursday as soon as it comes up
on Twitter I'm gonna be copy and putting
that everything where so I'm waiting for
your Pope to send that thing out but
yeah he said it at the end of chat so he
actually said it out there but yeah
waiting for the picture I'm honestly
waiting because the artist who does all
of their work ash I'm honestly just
waiting to see what she does because
between the cheetah and so there's one
thing that's Carol you may not know
there's been some comments on my channel
and it's kind of one of those things
that's been a joke most people have said
during my videos and stuff that I'm
always like very calm and collected
during like chaos and then somebody
basically said they like thought I was
kind of like the Bob Ross of Destiny so
there's kind of a joke going in there so
I've like a couple different things I
was trying to figure out how I'm working
with her to figure out what to do but
that's kind of like a joke and it kind
of kind of stuck with it it's like one
of those that it's just it makes some
sense but it's been kind of crazy so
we'll see it but yeah I was like I've
had that comment like more than once on
very far separate occasions and it just
made me and also one was like ASMR I'm
like I can't stand my own voice but if
you guys like it cool it's one of those
were like nobody can shout out to have
it guys by the way recently just another
tier 1 sub gifted to the iron Lords
podcast so guess what you are now a sub
to my channel you should have done that
first but that's on you supporter of the
channel gift and subs basically to
everybody out there so the huge love out
there to have it can myself chat but
yeah its advances everywhere big one
guys Scarah you have been amazing so I
just want to shout out to you and say
thank you for being here it's an
insanely overly long long point
flashpoint but I will go ahead and say
this is Eve on ttis and Cognito and
scare oh and scare oh let's give you the
last word tonight say it out boom thanks
for hanging out with us and it's been
the last word peace peace